une production du studio
SF bienvenue sans filtre le podcast où
on parle ce qu'on nos
invités qutin avec moi
PLO cette semaine on reçoit notre ami
notre bon
ami notre bon amie Vanessa
duchel avec qui en fait on collabore C
tempsci sur son nouveau podcast qui
maintenant déjà vu le jour que vous
connaissez sûrement déjà qui s'appelle
détestable un projet euh auquel on croit
beaucoup qu'on on croit beaucoup en elle
je pense que euh le concept est super
bon elle est super bonne est super drôle
euh super animatrice super invité un
podcast qui va cartonner jeen en doute
pas du tout en fait que en fait
aujourd'hui on a parlé de de de de de
plein d'affaires autres que son nouveau
projet aussi parce que juste pour
apprendre à mieux connaître cette
personne qui est vaniss duchel euh mais
elle nous a quand même raconté en fait
son histoire d'amour comment qu'elle a
rencontré sa blonde avec qui qui est
présentement puis son historique un peu
de dating qui est pas toujours été
évident puis ce qui a été la graine qui
a fait germer ce projet qui est
détestable puis on a parlé de culture
populaire de ce qu'on écoutait quand
qu'on était jeune les séries bi contre
les vampires tout ça c un petit peu
aussi pour ceux qui trip nostalgie 9
début 2000 vous allez vous reconnaître h
puis on a parlé aussi de diversité à
l'écran parce que Vanessa qui elle-même
fait partie de plusieurs diversités que
ce soit corporelle ou sexuelle euh puis
on a parler de la façon avec laquelle
les diversités étaient représentées dans
des émissions de culture populaire comme
notamment Occupation Double puis s'il y
avait vraiment une piste de solution ou
si c'était juste le concept qu'il
fallait scrapp tu sais de de A à Z une
réflexion quand même som toute assez
intéressante là où est-ce que où est-ce
qu'on a vu ça aller dans le fond des
dernières années l'esèce de tendance
d'Occupation Double de vouloir euh
quasiment nous nous nous nous forcer une
diversité qui au final était peut-être
pas de façon naturelle et efficace fait
qu'on discute de tout ça avec avec
Vanessa qui a un point de vue évidemment
super pertinent sur le sujet évidemment
on parle de son nouveau podcast puis by
the way DOM et moi on est all on est
allé sur son nouveau podcastit que si
vous aimez le sans filtre podcast checkz
le feed de détestable si vous voulez
nous entendre parler du monde du dating
là on s'ouvre comme jamais savoir tout
savoir ça êre crustillan crunchy
crunchy fa si vous voulez entendre plus
de ce gars qui VI dire ça ben allez éc
notre épisode sur détestable puis c'est
une belle façon de mettre votre pied à
l'eau sur un nouveau projet si vous
aimez déjà ce que nous on fait donc bon
podcast bonne écoute le podcast de cette
semaine est présenté par nos amis chez
manscape manscape qui sont avec nous
depuis le début et qui n'arrête pas de
lancer des nouvelles gammes de produits
des nouveaux packages absolument
incroyables notamment
celui-là pour la barbe don toi tu as une
moustache en ce moment Beni j'ai semi
moustache semibe souvent je rafraîchis
le mais à matin j'ai utilisé le Beard
Heder que ce matin pour juste moustache
dev juste un peu trop long puis là tu
bois ton verre de lait là ça TR dans ton
lait si tu veux pas ça moi je me
rappelle quand je me laissais pousser la
moustache trop longtemps quand je
faisais de la natation je je prenais
toujours deux gorgé g une première
gorgée avec mon gade pu après ça je me
lichais les babines pour avoir la
deuxième gorché ouais c'est ça c'est
c'est c'est ça peut être intéressant
mais en général c'est pe souhaitable m
fait que là j'ai juste comme avec mon be
hger découper ma moustache à la
perfection puis B c'est vraiment le
meilleur outil en fait pour tout ce qui
est pilocité faciale puis avoir la
longueur désirée
avoir ouais parce que en fait au lieu
d'avoir des des affes qui se rajoutent
dessus tu sais d'abitude tu arrives avec
deux ou trois cho choix de grandeur mais
ici il y a 20 choix de grandeur en fait
de 0.5 jusqu'à 10 puis ça ça permet
vraiment une personnalisation une grande
personnalisation de la longueur de votre
barbe moi je suis fort du goti tu sais
j'ai un bon g quand même une bonne
moustache puis un Beig communément
appelé le Beig fait j'ai décidé d'aller
vraiment in dans le BE fait ce que je
fais c'est que je me mets à TR sur les
joues puis après ça je me mets à 7 sur
le beigne c'est du bon c'est du bon enlè
ça c'est quand même du bon puis là ça
fait que à chaque fois que je fais ça
j'ai comme le beigne idéal le beigne que
je souhaiterais avoir en fait ben que
tout le monde essentiellement devrait
souhaiter avoir bref pro à moins que tu
a autre chose à dire sur tout le package
quiire c'est que ça vient avec un kit au
complet là tu sais on pourrait passer
une heure en en parler avec passion mais
bref il y a tu sais il y a un shampoing
il y a une crème il y a il y a un ping
il y a une brosse il a des ciseaux tout
ce qu'il faut pour avoir la la barbe la
moustache tout ce que vous voulez dans
le visage idéal donc si vous voulez y
aller pour offrir ce kit là ou n'importe
quel kit de mancake que vous nous
entendez parler depuis des années
maintenant utilisez le code promo sans
filtre pour 20 % de Rabet et la
livraison gratuite puis vous allez pas
le regretter je vous le dis fait merci
mcape et merci à vous d'encourager le
sansfil podcast oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
yeah
[Musique]
euh c'est ça je pense pas que ça va être
les mêmes qui qui ont écouté nèement
peut-être le podcast des de finances
personnelles qu'on a fait 2 semaines là
tu sais genre fait qu' y a quand même
cette espèce de rotation là mais c'est
quand même le fun de tu tu trouves ce
que ce que tu veux dans le 100 % mais ça
m'a fait ça aussi avec sous écoute
j'étais accro fan patréon le kit ouais
je l'ai écouté pendant des années pu
moment donné j'ai juste fait comme ah
cette semaine ça ça me tente pas j'ai
découvert un autre podcast là finalement
je suis tombé àro l'autre podcast
mais puis après ça ben j'avais commê pu
le l'étincel mais ça reste un podcast
que j'ai aimé pendant des années puis
probablement si je l'IS écouter demain
je fis comment ouais j'en écouterai
encore tu sais mais là pour le moment je
je t'en pause je tentit bre je pense
c'est normal sais y une limite tellement
d'offres que il y a une limite de T to à
louer à écouter des podcasts là il
faudrait juste faire ça pour pouir
écouter toutes les podcasts qu'on aime
mais j'écoute aussi beaucoup de podcast
d'horreur ah ouais le TR crime genre
j'en ai écouté beaucoup mais là
j'aiad genre c'est des des gars ben
c'est souvent des gars que j'écoute en
tout cas qui raconte des histoires
d'horreur que soit que les abonnés leur
envoyé soit qu' ont vu sur redit fait
que c'est vraiment des des histoires des
histoires vraies d'horreur ben ça peut
être vrai ou pas mais c'est souvent des
histoires mettons c'est était travailler
à tel endroit tel endroit un St qui
arrive plus elle réussi à se sauver pu
ça fait c'est sûr que ça ça éveille un
peu là mon stress là quand je suis en
des fois mais je suis obligé de mettre
ça mais c'est quoi c'est Alanis
dernièrement qui qui a fait une vidéo
elle a commencé à courir beaucoup comme
pris son cel puis a dit je suis la seule
fille qui se sent pas bien genre des
fois quand je croise du monde ça CCL tu
sais puis là elle partager une vidéo
après c'est juste une fille qui court il
y a un ch qui arrive à côté puis là il y
a un gars qui arrive en courant en
arrière puis là le gars il fait juste
comme la poignée il vole son affaire
genre se déb un peu pu il rentre dans le
CH puis il s'en va ouais mais la vidéo a
fait vraiment peur parce que la personne
derrière a zigzag un peu pu la molle
sais on dirait genre à
ralenti à suiv vraiment le le pot de la
fille pu on voit qu'elle se retourne un
peu puis elle continue à marcher puis je
suis comme à courir puis je me dis oh my
god oh my god qu'est-ce tu mais ça
l'aire pas non c'est ça c'est ça qui me
fascine tu vois quelqu'un qui qui qui
est dans ton dos quasiment comme un un
sac à dos qui est dans dans ses culottes
puis elle là à cour quand même au même
rythme s'est dit peut-être qu'elle
voulait pas faire tu sais des fois là
moi des fois tu dis jeux je veux pas
genre avoir l'air de la fille qui a peur
de quelquunouou c'est ça que je me dis
des fois depuis que j'abit puis à
Montréal là j'ai j'ai plus peur à
Montréal qu'avanté je sortais de chez LZ
puis c'était vraiment là faisait noir
noir noir no noir puis j'étais parqué
dans une petite rue puis j'avais peur
j'ai marché 5 minutes j'avais peur puis
com j'hité 10 ans ici j'ai jamais eu
peur plus j'habite plus là puis
maintenant j'ai peur tu sais mais
j'écoute tellement de cochonnerie aussi
bah c'est peut-être ça ouais c'est
peut-être ça mais tu sa en même temps si
quelqu'un traversait la rue en même
temps que moi quelqu'un qui qui était
louche mainon qui me paraissait louche
louche je sais pas si j'aurais voulu
qu'il se sente mal puis que je change de
trottoir c'est ex fait que j'aurais
continue quand même en même temps je
pense qu'il y a rien de négatif à
vouloir assurer sa sécurité non non
c'est ça exact puis tu sais moi ça
m'arrive des fois de me poser ces
questions là puis je pas une fille tu
sais je quand j'ai vu ça il y avait Alex
santomo aussi qui est une fille du West
Island contenu sur sur
Instagram qui avait eu qui sétait fait
unz agressé je me Rapp plus c'est quoi
les détails mais elle sétait fa agressé
par quelqu'un en courant en jogant puis
là elle a dit je peux plus y aller
juste j'imagine même pas moi vivre ça
moi je me dis tout le temps est-ce que
les gens vont m'attaquer parce que je
suis grosse je me dis est-ce qu'ils vont
se dire est forte ou je pouris pas la
sais mais en même temps je cours pas
vite je comme ils se disent cours pas
vite mais ça se peut qu'elle soit forte
c'est difficile à déplacer tu sais je me
demande si d'être grosse ça peut
m'avantager à quelque part ben je pense
que oui parce que dans tous les cas si
je vois une fille en avant de moi mant
jetais un agresseur je vois une fille en
avant de moi il y a pas beaucoup de
filles qui vont être capable de sauver
la course fait que tu es mieux d'être
grosse puis de pas te sauver puis mieux
d'être for c'est mieux d'être dur à
déplacer dans le fou ça tu es peut-être
pas assez fort pour me soulever là mais
non exact en fait tu sais c'est ça exact
ouais tuallais-tu dire non je suis
vraiment chistement pas assez fort pour
te soulever non mais j'allais dire je
suis pas assez fort pour soulever
n'importe qui mais effectivement là
ouais mais c'est ça mais tu sais mettons
un kidnapping moi je serais pas victime
de ça je pense là à moins qu'il soit H
là ou avec un couteau peut-être aussi là
ouais tu leur donnerais tes sûr je leur
donnerai tout ce que je possède même mes
kilos je leur donnerai tout
non mais sérieux je trouve que c'est
c'est épouvantable puis de plus en c'est
de plus en plus dangereux j'ai
l'impression parce que on dirait que
peut-être parce qu'on on entend plus
parler aussi là mais on dirit que c'est
de plus en plus dangereux Montréal en
particulier il y a des crmes aussi à la
Valle où je réside mais rese que
Montréal c'est ça qu'on entend tout le
temps parler puis les quartiers il y a
plus il y a plus de quartier
nécessairement safe j'ai l'impression tu
sais ouais je sais pas si c'est la covid
qui a augmenté tout ça ou c'est juste le
monde qui devient de plus en plus fou
probblement un mélange des deux
probblement mélange des deux pourquoi tu
as bougé à laaval ma blonde ah ouais
hein mais en fait si je veux si je veux
vraiment sérieusement c'est parce que
parce que ça c'était ta réponde vraiment
g l'autre réponse c'est
genre je suis pas triste mais c'est
c'est juste parce que j'habitais avec
une amie à Montréal puis là mon
beau-père est décédé pu là ma mère elle
avait un petit peu de de misère à être
solo tu sais s rem pas vraiment encore
aujourd'hui ça fait 3 ans puis pu c'est
ça fait que me demandé si je pouvais
aller avec elle une coupe de mois tu
sais juste le temps que puis c'est ça je
allé comme 5 mois pu la covid est
arrivée puis ma mère travaillit dans un
CHSLD ah ouais fait que là moi je suis
asthmatique puis hypocondrique donc
j'étais là oh my god qu'est-ce que
paniquer paniquer ouais je j'is je
capotais bien r chez nous puis je
faisais des lives à tous les jours pour
me divertir puis Maé ma mère elle m'a
dit bon on a un premier C de de covid au
SLD j'ai fait au fait là m'a dit V H si
je v pas te faire rendurer ça vant ma
mère av pas peur c'est mais c'est ça
fait que là je suis parti je all VI avec
Rosalie le sort puis LZ pendant une
coupe de mois ouais je rappelle ça puis
après ça pendant la pandémie j'ai
rencontré ma ma blonde puis je devais
partir en France en 2021 pour faire de
Voice h puis la journée la semaine que
je vais partir les frontiè on fermé fait
que là ça annulé mon aventure là-bas
fait que là ma blonde m'avait dit ben
tant qu' aller en France payer ton ton
appartement tous les Moot je sais pas
combien de temps tu vas rester là-bas h
plus on apparte avec Rosalie amène tes
affaires chez nous va vivre ton
expérience pu quand tu reviendras on
verra qu'est-ce qu'on fait tu sais sa
que les affaires étaient chez eux déjà
exact puis elle av dans un petit 3 et
demi à la Valle fait que là j'avais tout
mon St quand j'ai débarqué mon stock
là-bas ma blonde capoté était comme
voyant tuas autant d'f j'ai dis ton
stock je pensais là de
TR l non les camion de déménagement qui
arrivve j'avais un L King j'avais comme
mes commodes tout mon linge plein d'enf
que j'avais laissé che mes parents aussi
qu'il fallait que que j'amène mer sais
puis eu fait que c'est ça fait que on un
petit peu capoté au début puis euh là
finalement je partais pas fait que là on
est resté comme 4 5 mois chez eux à la
Val on a trouvé un appartement plus
grand bah oui vraiment là parce que en
plus on é en télétvail fait que là on
avait un gros ZILO parce que c'estit un
immense ZILO comme ça mettons
puis on travaillait chacun là mais tu
c'est r 24h 24 ensemble depuis le 20 20
juin 2021 on est tout le temps puis là
ça faisait pas tant longtemps en plus
que vous connaissiez 6 mois c'est ça
c'est risqué quand même là gen on se
confine ensemble moi c'est ma première
relation sérieuse à vie ah ouais ouais
comment est-ce que quelqu'un
hypocondrique avec des facteurs de
risque la covid rencontre quelqu'un
pendant la covid G semble que moi tu me
décris ton profil puis je fais genre moi
je reste dans ma maison puis je fais
aller tout chier je me fais livrer du G
puis je désinfecte tout en rentrant mais
c'est ce qu'on faisait les filles quand
j'is arrivé chez chez VO Rosalie Rosalie
ouais je leur avais dit je vais
déménager avec toi rosal ça me dérange
pas sauf que il faut maintenant qu'on
désinfecte tout ce qu'on ce qu'on reçoit
on il y a personne qui vient si tu me
promets ça je v venir sinon je viendrai
pas tu sais c'est correct sa tu veux pas
mais moi je peux pas puis les filles ont
vraiment été fines à chaque com et puis
qu'on faisait probement c'était même pas
moi qui allait là parce que j'avais trop
peur c'était les filles qui allaient
puis on désinfectait tout quand qu'
rentrait puis y a personne qui venait
sauf un moment donné qu' a des amis au
filles qui sont venus puis j'étais en T
oh my god j'avais tellement peur puis en
plus je savais que c'est des personnes
pas sérieuse cétait des humoristes puis
autes sont pas sérieux toujours en train
de faire des jokes sur exact exact puis
là j'étais là mais non mais qu'est-ce
que vous faites mais c'est vrai c'est
pas une joke la covid la gang puis là
j'étais vraiment pas contente ça a créé
une petite discord mais tout ça pour
dire que ma blonde je l'ai rencontré
pendant ça puis j'avais dit une semaine
avant on voit personne on voit personne
puis on se teste avant de se voir je
sais même pas si on avait des tests non
je pense même qu'on avait des test à ce
moment début non ouais j'avais juste dit
qu'on voit personne fait que pendant une
semaine on n pas vu personne av vous
voyez pour la première fois fait que
vous parliez euh
FaceTime pendant une semaine on dirait
que tout ça a jamais existé c'est genre
tu me racontes des affaires des des
trucs qu'on qu'on tu sais juste aller à
l'épisserie mon que c'était genre la fil
à M lave les mains rentre là pas plus
que 100 dans les les petit parcours de
flèch après ça on se teste on on on voit
personne 10 jours avant le parté de Noël
avec le grand-père c'est fou pareil hein
mais moi j'aimais quand même ça pour
être honête je voudrais pas qu'on
revienent en tempre de où est-ce que
tout le monde Meur là c'est pas ça mais
c'est plus que moi je suis bien fan de
de tout ça tu sais de
de film
postapocalyptique moi mon émission
préférée c'était bffi contre les
vampires fait que là je me sentais des
fois sais comme je la nuit de terreur
une maison Hée puis je me sentais comme
dans bille fait que j'étais bien tu sais
j'aimais ça j'étais j'étais comme j'éis
une super héroïne c'est ce qui se
passait pendant la pandémie aussi
j'étais comme ce qu'on vit là c'est un
peu comme d'un film fait que ça me
faisait me sentir comme dans un film h
tuta plus team Angel ou comment
s'appelait l'autre Spike
Drake ressemble quand même c'est vrai ça
ça ressemble Spike Spike ou spik était
débile Spike vous connaissez ça oui éc
moi mon premier girl crush c'est page ah
ouais je peux comprendre cette actrice
là je l'ai toujours trouvé complètementb
oua page ouais c'était comme l'espèce de
Némésis de c'est pas Cordelia non non
Cordelia c'est le vampire ok parce que P
c'est une autre chasseuse
de C la méchante mais bit comm la me
ouais c'est ça mais pas les lu B il
estlu il y avait page aussi ok qui était
élu parce que bi est morte ah elle est
morte mais est revenue à la vie fait le
temps qu' qu' meure il a une nouvelle
élu sais puis tuas-tu écoutéj aussi ou
non non ça moi là David borianas ça
jamais été
mon SP ah 100 % je le trouvais trop
licheux je tout le temps
comme non vous trouvez pas faut j'avoue
que mon souvenir est quand même sœur
non h capota semble me semble souvirenir
j'ai un souvenir j'ai un souvenir de
Sarah mode ben moi j'allais dire Sarah
mode sûrement capotais sur ça c'est ça
se peut ça se peut ce que tu dis là
c'est possible me souviens qu' manée
j'étais chez vous elle écouter bofy pu
était comme oh my god je sens qu'Angel
va arriver je sens qu'Angel va arriver
puis là gen Angel sort d'un buisson j'is
comme comment
fait je peux vraiment comprendre que
cette histoire là tu as marqué plus que
moi parce que c'est voir ça c'est genre
quand même assez
frappant voir ce que tu viens de me
décrire il va arriver je sens je sens il
s'en vient il s'en vient il arrive genre
à ce moment-là elle a dû dire à ce
momentl qu' éit connecté avec ouais is
ben je vais lui demander je v demander
d'écouter ça puis de me dire si c'est
c'est vrai mais CIT vraiment mon mon
émission là oua ouais oh vraiment puis
aujourd'hui je pense que ça fait comme
10 ans que c'est terminé c'est pas plus
probablement plus que ça
plus là quand même ouais ouais ouais
mais ouais je je le réécouterai parce
queil y avait tellement de bijoux là de
réalisation je trouvais tu sais il y
avait des épisodes où estce que il y
avait de la CIT comme un peu une comédie
musicale puis tout le monde se mettait à
chanter danser puis il y avait des
c'était c'était comme on dirait je sais
pas si était plusieurs réalisateurs
faudrait que je m'informe là-dessus mais
c'était tellement Nice de voir qu' était
ouvert à aller n'importe où puis il pas
qu'il se foutaient de leur public c'est
pas ça tout mais dans le sens que il y
avait avait pas peur sa aujourd'hui on
se à quelque chose parce que ça
fonctionne fait qu'on reste là tu sais
on essaie pas trop d'affaair t que le
chanté qu' se permettait puis je
trouvais ça fucking
Nice ce que tu viens de dire là j'avais
cette discussion là pas plus tard que
que avant hier avec quelqu'un que vous
savez c'est qui mais que je vais pas
nommer là avec qui j'étais pendant le
weekend mais on parlait d' quel point
étant donné que maintenant le le système
de d'émission de télé de médias
traditionnel à la télévision et est
quand même est en déclin puis on nime
mieux s'assurer de faire un genre de
genre de formule qui qui marche qu'on
sait qu' va marcher correct même si ça
marche pas super même si ça c'est déjà
mieux que de prendre un risque sur
quelque chose qui pourrait chier mainon
mais c'est en prenant des risque sur
d'autres affaires que tu fais des trucs
comme ça qui sort puis à ce moment-là
quand quand c'était ces émissions là je
me rappelle
début 2000 fin 90 des émissions même il
y en avait tellement tu sa genre juste
le louarou du campus mettons là c'était
si louarou campus là puis genre tu
verrais pas le louarou du campus
maintenant tu sais c'était trop champ
gauche là pour ce que maintenant on
écoute pu c'est quand qui est là vaut
mieux faire une autre saison d'udé qu'on
sait que le moins bon Daudé va être
meilleur que n'importe quoi qu'on
proposerait sur cette plage hire là là
tu sais mais j'ai l'impression que tu
sais j'ai la misire à formuler mon idée
correctement mais
que on veut maintenant on veut tellement
être politically correct que la qualité
prend un coup parce que puis les gens je
pense qu'on est un peu hypocrite en tant
que société parce que on veut pas voir
de Cham mettons dans od on était contre
l'intimidation mais il y en a pas fait
qu'oncoute pas ça tu saisou fait je
pense que tu pas cris veut pas on a pas
le choix ben la télé a pas le choix de
de s'accommoder à ça puis
en résulte qu' en résulte là tu sais
mais il y a personne qui était choqué là
dansun kardachian quand qui se tapait
dans face pu que dans aucune dans le
bachelorette quand qu' s'envoyait chier
puis qu' se traitait toutes les noms là
puis mais ici c'est ça il y a comme
quelque chose qui fait que tout le monde
veut défendre toutes les causes
aujourd'hui puis je pense pas non plus
que les paroles sont alignées toujours
avec les bottines là ouais tu sais
mettons parlant de risque tu sais
mettons mon di office c'est moi depuis
coup d'année c'est mon émission préférée
pu jamais écouté ah ouais c'est vrai
c'est une des plus grandes choses que
l'humanité a créé c'est incroyable mais
genre justement sais mett ça c'est une
émission que au moment qu'il l'ont fait
c'était vraiment risqué parce que sa
c'était complètement différent des
autres genes de qui avait s à
l'époque post friends mod il y av encore
des rires en CAN encore c'était vraiment
plus je sais pas là léger là tu sais tis
que tu sa les office c'est vraiment
l'Our vent plus cru sais il y a des
personnages sont vraiment genre idiot
mais genre racistes et sexiste
puis puis un peu comme Caméra Café
cétait raciste sexiste camé café ah
ouais hein non mais tu
assumé c'est ça sais dans le sens que il
y a des personnages qui sont comme ça
mais aussi d'autres personnages qui tu
sais que qui sont l'ARB ça dans le sens
que tu sais c'est pas juste l'émission
en tant que tel est pas
raciste puis
pu sais au début le monde Je ça a
presque été cancellé ce show là prière
saison 2è saison parce que c'était comme
trop nouveau puis c'était comme un style
d'humour ben là on s c'était quand même
choquant je pense je supposer de ça tu
sais justement céit full des malaises pu
je pense qu' au début le monde était
était inconfortable mais là finalement
ça a été le plus grand succès sais
aujourd'hui c'est comme puis tu sais
j'aiécoutais just un podcast sur The
Office puis c'était le le gars qui fait
Kevin
qui un podcast puis il pose toujours la
question ses invités qui sont c'est
souvent d'autres membres du cast penstu
qu'on pourrait faire ça aujourd'hui des
offic tout le monde dit non puis lui il
fait mais c'est l'émission La
aujourd'hui ça fait ça c'est fini on a
fini de ça depuis 10 ans mais sur
Netflix c'est l'émission la plus écoué
tu sais fait genre tu sais il y a comme
un un genre de de de de de disconnect
entre on on le ferait plus mais c'est ça
qui marche le
plus c'est exactement ce que je disais
c'est vraiment ça mais moi j'ai j'ai pas
écouté ça c'est niaise parce que il fit
un temps que les j'avais vu un podcast
deux personnes noir qui qui en parlaient
j'ai dit n noir mais noir il était juste
noir deux personnes noires qui qui en
parlait puis qui disait que friends the
office était trop blanc tu sais puis moi
mon père est noir puis puis à l'époque
j'étais comme mais j'écouterai pas ça
ouais ouais si c'est trop blanc
j'écouterai pas ça puis ça m'est resté
on dirait que j'ai juste jamais
pourtant tu sais j'écoute plein
d'affaire de que c'est juste des des
personnes blanches c'est vraiment juste
parce que je me suis senti si si les
Noirs disent que c'est trop blanc il do
avoir quelque chose que ça va pas être
Nice dedans j'écoute pas ça j'ai comme
boycot mais ouais je me suis fait dire
par tellement de personnes que puis jeux
pas généraliser c'est pas tous les noirs
qui disent ça c'est le podcast que
j'avais écouté là ouais ouais mais tu
mais ça fait sens parce qu'en même temps
sais ça se passe en Pennsylvanie puis
c'est des personnages blan les
personnages principaux sont blancs mais
je veux dire di office c'est quand même
il y a quand même un personnage noir un
personnage indienne il personnage
mexicain puis les thématiques
de de de de de de de race là si tu veux
en anglais sais c'est comme ça fait
partie des du du discours de l'émission
c'est pas juste comme on parle pas de
tout ça là tu sais c'est comme ça fait
partie des thèmes là mettons fa c'est
quand même intéressant je trouve ce
quand j'aiécouté ça je comme ok c'est
vraiment plus euh plus de Nuan plus plus
plus Nuan plus de nuances puis plus
progressiste entre guillemets que bien
d'autres sitcom que c'est juste comme on
parle pas de ça ouais ouais mais surtout
friends j'imagine parce que c'est pas
juste parce qu'il il y a pas néement de
personnes noir c'est plutôt que les
situation
euh les les les événements tout ce qui
se passe là-dedans c'est pas les
personnes noires se était pas comme
interpellé par ça c'était pas leur
quotidien c'est pas leurs enjeux tu sais
fait que c'est peut-être pas né parce
qu'il y a pas de personne noir mais
parce que c'est les enjeux que eux
autres il ont pas au quotidien puis que
tu sais c'est niaiseux mais j'ai vu une
influenceur que j'adore est vraiment
gentil tout le quit mais en fin de
semaine qui av des problèmes de je sais
pas comment faire pour pas qu'on
l'identifie là de transport mettons puis
euh elle disait est-ce que c'est parce
qu'il y avait une carte cadeau pour
payer un taxi
non mais jamais non mais ça j'enis faire
de ça puis en tout cas longue histoire
il est pas méchant il est pas de tout de
tous les échos que j'ai c'est vraiment
un super typ ah oui vraiment vraiment il
a mal entendu puis si on avait une
caméra qui nous filmait tout le temps
quand qu'on a l' le plus cave de notre
vie ben on aurait l'air cave en toi en
train chier dans le B ouais hier pu
m'ess avec des feuilles là c'était pas
super mais to le jugement de pas tAUTO
filmer quand tu fa ouais au kom 63 ma
première crotte dans le bois la main
plein de merde ça ser même drôle par
exemple ouais ouais ouais ouais mais ça
arê bon com tu as pas le temps de faire
ça dans le fond c'est c'est quoi 5
minutes de plus ou de moins là tu sais
ouais j'avoue mais tu AAS pas fini 10è
euh oui je pense que oui encore bon peu
importe il se V pas important fait que
c'est ça fa cette personne là parlait de
son transport puis elle disait comme ah
là ça pas de bon sang il ont il ont pas
fait t affaire fait que là faut que je
retourne chez nous puis que je revienne
puis là là j'espère qu'il vont mettre en
classe à
faire pourquoi puis après ça a dit
j'aimerais ça vraiment vous montrer
comme ça a l'air de quoi la classe la
première classe c'est vraiment je ve
vraiment vous montrer fait que là dis
mais à tag la compagnie tu sais fait
finalement elle a réussi à ah ouais puis
est retourné en première classe pu elle
a fait des stories pour montrer comment
céit na de pouvoir s'asseoir se coucher
puis le champ puis tout ça mais tu sais
son public je crois a pas 3500 dollars
de plus à mettre pour une classe à faire
puis c'est pas un enjeu que qu'on a
quotidiennement tu sais de savoir si on
achète une classe le monde tout ce qui
essaie en ce moment c'est de se payer un
appartement d'aller à fucking
[Musique]
éperie c'est comm oui mais oui la
prochaine fois prendre ouais Chris elle
a raison dans le fond tuas l'air mieux
ouais manger du saumon sais mais c'est
juste que ce genre de prème là ça me
fait penser à à friends m que que c'est
pas des
gens mais c'est ça puis moi non plus ça
m'interpelle pas pas tout c'est pas ma
réalité de voir je dis pas que je vais
voir 10 gros SEM dans un show qui ça
s'appelle fat friends c'est pas ça mais
c'est plus que je comme moi mon problème
c'est pas de savoir quelle robe de haute
couture je vais mettre là c'est vraiment
une robe qui va me faire que je que je
vais réussir à trouver d'ici de
semainesis fait ça m'interpelle pas P
tout mais je peux comprendre pourquoi ça
interpelle beaucoup de monde la majorité
est blanche et mince donc je peux
comprendre ce que tu viens de dire là
c'est pendant que tu le disais je
réfléchissais à d'autres exemples de de
séries télé tu sais mett ouais c'est
tout du monde qui sont
hautement successful dans ce qu'ils font
ouais tout du monde que l'argent n'est
pas un enjeu il habite à à New York dans
un espèce de gros appart à tous les
soirs sont au restaurant tu sais c'est
potentiellement ce qui fait aussi que
des offic c'est du monde qui travaille
de 8 à 4 là oui c'est du mond qui
travaille à lowend job dans une firme
vraiment pas si glamour là tu sais ouais
puis là c'est quandok c'est mettons
Michael qui qui
déclare une banque route là comme une
banque route ouais c'est gen ou il
déclare une faillette ouais c'est c'est
comme ouais dans le fond c'est ça tu
sais la vraie vie ouais c'est ça puis
qu' leur arrive des choses vraiment
normal normal pas extraordinaire puis
que puis que c'est ça c'est ça un peu le
mais on été chanceux parce que
habituellement j'ai l'impression que
c'est un ou l'autre tu sais soit qu'il
faut qu'il soit vraiment pauvre soit que
so faut que soit vraiment riche j'avais
déjà fait des pitch de d'émissions que
j'avais écrit avec moi-même puis j'étais
comme avec qui on a fait des grandes
sessions d'écriture là c'est ça puis on
m'a dit tu sais faut vraiment que ça
soit plus grandiose tu sais là faut que
ça soit pas un appartement que ça soit
un loft un espèce en brique tu sais faut
que la job ça soit dans un endroit où
est-ce que c'est vraiment c'est vitré
lumineux le monde est bien habillé là
j'étais comme ah ouais mais tu es pas
dans un 4 et demi étudiant avec deux
c'est ça mais pourtant j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a plein de séries peut-être
qu'on est rendu là mais il y a plein de
séries dans notre passé surtout au
Québec que c'est quand même modeste tu
sais ont ils sont pas riches
littéralement 4 et demi la série 4 de
finalement il y avait un vétérinaire
dans gang mais tout le monde habitait
dans un appart ben normal mais oui mais
mais sous sont vraimentou ça fait
longtemps quand même cé bon c'était quoi
déjà l'émission avec alin Zouvi là il y
avait des animaux dedans dans dans
l'émission ouais CIT quoi l'émission je
sais pas j'ai aucune idée ah ça
absolument rien c'est avec qui déjà moi
j'aimais bien le
duo c'est flou pour toi aussi oui c'est
mes surs il avaient enregistré sur des
cassettes puis ma sœur Alexandra elle
avait toutes les cassettes de 4 et demi
une c'est 4 ETI CIT bffi bah de toute
évidence selon les souv ouais c'est ça s
ça moi avec Marilou j'écé Darson Creek
ah ça ma troisème sœur c'est Darson
Creek non c'est deux frères ah oui c'est
ça pas deux frères le groupe là mais les
frères SCOT pas deux frères c'était quoi
de frère demi frère l'émission
avec c'est D là son drog ah oui oui avec
beno ang anglais cétait-tu deux frères
tu deux frères deux frères ça
ouais BO anglais je me rappelle il était
allé à fortbyard puis était resté coincé
dans un dans un genre de tunnel là
cétait genre tu sais une genre de
glissade dos mais sans eau genre fallait
qu'il rentre là-dedans puis était il
était tellement grand ce g là qui était
comme resté coincé tu sais des fois là
était grand on a grand des affaires de
même qui jou à Télé là tu sais mettons
juste des fois le samedi soir la télé
était ouverte puis ça c'est genre un
souvenir que j'ai mais hors contexte
complet là je me rappelle pas j'étais où
je me rappelle pas comment j'ai vu ça je
me rappelle juste de voir Benoît
l'anglais dans un Tuy pas de sortir de
là à fondvoyant mais ça puis ça j'ai
l'impression je vais m'en rappeler
jusqu'à ce que je Meur mais honnêtement
je vois pas pourquoi j' oublierais ce
souvenir là que là je viens de ressortir
j'ai pas pensé ça doit faire 10 ans que
j'ai pas pensé à ça j'ai r des souvenirs
de même Mo ça existe dans ma tête je me
souviens qu'à ma fête de 7 ans j'avais
demandé pour ma fête je voulais manger
du PFK j'avais eu du PFK puis j'étais
fucking content mais tu te rappelles ma
fa de 7 ans je m'en souviens mais tu
sais tes parents qui faisaient tout pour
te donner des bons cadeaux pu te faire
du plaisir toutes tes autres fites toi
la seule que tu te rappelles c'est quand
tu as eu du PFK à 7 7 ans mais quand
j'is je je tripais sur PFK c'était genre
mon rêve Ctait de travailler sur PFK moi
j'aimais tellement ça là le premier Mo
je suis pas végan je suis pas végan
parce que j'aimais pas la viande là
parce que des fois je passe à côté d'un
PFK pu ch sauce là ah que je ça sent bon
ah ouais moi ça me lev le cœur toujours
ah ouais c'est trop gros les frites trop
gr tout ce qui est trop gros frit j'aime
pas ça ah ouais mais fr m les j'aime ça
mais dans le sens que genre tout ce qui
est frit les la panure ça me lève le
cœur mais en tout cas mais ce que je
voulais dire par rapport à ça c'est que
je sais pas si c'est dans votre podcast
que j'avais entendu ça chrisan page qui
disait que les souvenirs se déformés
ouais ouais fait peut-être que vos
souvenir sont c'est peut-être pas exact
pas vrai souvenir c'est peut-être en
fait que je pourrais essayer de trouver
la cassette de fortbyard puis que il
était pas pgné dans le tuyau pe-être que
juste dans ma tête je m'imaginais moi
dans un tuyau qui glisse pas puis
m'imaginez moi poigné mais lui a juste
passé à travers le tuyau peut-être
correct là ou peut-être était même dans
l'eau peut-être qu' était même dans
l'eau pas tout à for Boyard finalement
il jou match de tennis tu étais comment
forbyard mais c'est fou forbyard quand
tu penses à ça genre c'était il amenait
toute une équipe de de crew il amené du
monde de l'UDA jusqu'à fortbyard pour
fil forbyard c'est genre en France ouais
c'est ça pour filmer une émission grande
envergure ça devait coûter des des
pelletés et des pelletés juste un
épisode de Fort boy ça aa été quoi votre
défi que vous auriez pas relevé mettons
Mo quand qu' a des araignées là ouais
j'allais dire aussi dans plein d'araigné
gen pas moi toi ça te dérange pas ben je
fer pas ça chaque matin
mais se réveiller avant comment avir une
belle journée quelqu tentu non mais non
j'aime pas les araignées mais dans le
sens que tu me demandes de sauter dans
l'eau de devoir non j'ai jusqu'à un
affire pour aller chercher une clé ouais
ouais non tu sais je suis allé dans le S
dernièrement puis juste j'adore l'eau
j'adore le le la la plage et tout ça
mais h quand je chantais un peu trop de
courant puis que je sais plus à terre
j'avis pas de F h fait que j' mimagine
pas aller dans cette eau houleuse là
parce que quand même ça avait l'air de
de brasser en tabarnach de se rendre
jusqu'à là-bas prendre la clam tes deux
canine puis de revenir puis de monter la
Core la gros filet là ouais maisi tu
vois au contraire moi c'est genre
d'affire je feris comme fuck ouais ouais
moi ouais moi aussi je Seris comme yeah
on fait ça
malade c'est c'est mon premier défi à od
j'ai perdu c'est ça là c'est quoi
fallait fallait qu'on arge jusqu'à une
bouée avec genre un drapeau il y avait
des défis à od là il y a nageur genre le
meilleur au Canada genre il perd le défi
de nage qui le premier défi qui tu l'as
perdu ouis je me suis rendu au Boué
avant tout le monde mais j'avais mal
compris la consigne puis je cherchais
des drapeaux sur la bouée pu finalement
les drapeau était au bout d'une corde
qui pendait dans Boué dans le fond fait
que là j'ai passé deux Boué en pensant
qu'il y avait rien mais il y avait deux
drapeaux c'est Boué je aurais pu les
ramener puis gagner mais ah ouais tuas
pas écouté consiges ben il c'était mal
expliqué mais comment y avit des défis à
Audi mais il y avait quelques défis des
fois ben il y a des défis a des défis il
y a des Occupation Double tu écoute ça
oui j'écoute ça ben il y a des défis des
fois non c'est quoi dé fill ben c'est
genre un petit truc physique ou un petit
genre puis là tu GES de quoi
je comprends ouais j'entends ce que tu
me dis non mais c'est ça tu vois don des
privilèges tu VO nuit de l'amour là
c'est vrai il ont des petits ou qui plug
quelque chose nu de l'amour ouais ouais
ok je comprends c'est vrai ouais mais je
savais pas que c'était aussi physique
moi tu la dernière fois c'est cette
saisonci là mais c'est r c'est comme ça
c'est rare c'est le genre d'affaire de
Mme fallait qu'il bench 30 fois puis
qu'il saute sur un un affaire des
élastiques de même puis après ça c'estc
fitnessout c ané to non tu l'cout c
année ouais mais j'ai pas le choix mais
l'écoute mais mais mais pas que j'aime
pas ça j'aime ça tu sais ça pique ma
curiosité tout ça puis je me demande à
chaque année j'espère de voir de la
diversité mais en même temps j'espère
pas ouais parce que je suis comme j'
j'aimerais ça qu'il a une fille un peu
plus enrobée des personnes asiatiqu noir
pu importe puis finalement à chaque fois
je les vois là je suis comme pourquoi
j'ai souhaité ça sont jamais son tu sais
c'est c'est malheureusement c'est eux
autres qui partent en premier la par du
temps surtout si c'est des filles
racisées tu sais ou des filles grosses
là c'est eux qui vont partir en premier
là à moins qu'ils fasse vraiment rire tu
sais s's sont vraiment drôles peut-être
qu'ils vont pouvoir rester même même à
ça tu sais je me rappelle Julie Mar
quand qui était allé tu sais de la façon
qu'on interprétait le show Julie est
incroyable des fois je l'ai rencontré
vraiment vraiment SMAT oui puis c'est
comme tuas tu as l'impression que c'est
vraiment cool qu' soit là mais tu as
comme l'impression qu'elle reste là
parce que les gars veulent pas avoir
l'air des gars euh qui l'élimineent
mettons ouais parce que clairement
rapidement ça a comme paru que Julie
avait pas de match là-bas là tu sais
sauf que comme il éliminait d'autres
monde pu tu sais tourna un peu autour de
de cette affaire là fait j'ai
l'impression que c'est comme pas contre
productif mais que comment tu brilles C
trou là dans le fond de représentativité
dans des shows de même ben je pense
qu'il faudrait que tout le monde soit de
un ouvert ou et ou différent tu sais
parce que à la base je je sais pas si ça
se fait déjà mais de demander à au 10 g
Mons vous mettons qu' une fille ta plus
qui est là est-ce que vous l'ignorez ou
vous acceptez une dte avec vous allez en
voyage avec mais il y a pas un gars qui
va répondre non dans le sens à cette
question là il y a pas un gars qui va
répondre non en entrevue pour aller à a
tu sais ça va jamais c'est juste que
c'est ça mais si tous tes candidats
mettons sont genre pileepoil standard de
beauté genre toutes les gars fucking
genre musclé épilé puis genre le fade
parfait là tu sais pu parfait m ouais
ouais non je sais ce que tu veux dire
puis genre c'est sûr que là tu sais si
toutes tes candidats genre sil sont de
même c'est parce que les autres ont un
certain idéal de c'est quoi la beauté
puis c'est sûr qu'il recherche
l'équivalent de cette idéal là chez
l'autre puis là mettons tu dis ok B on
veut juste mettre une personne
différente pour comme avir la diversité
sur le show c'est sûr que cette personn
là va être en marge mais si si tu en as
plusieurs puis que c'est tout le monde
est différ ben là je dire après ça
ouais le point le point de ma question
cétait plutôt de dire comment qu'on
brise cette chaîn là parce que je suis
sûr que si od
alors en recevant le le les auditions il
y avait eu de la misère lui plein de
mond
pas mais ouais je suis sûr que c quand
quand ont passé les auditions s'il y
avait des options de gens de la
diversité mais je suis persuadé que
quand tu vas voir la représentativité du
monde qui vont passer les auditions d'
ça doit pas être très diverse comme
personne d' dans fil d'attente je pense
que c'est un cycle aussi tu sais si tu
vois que c'est ça si tu vois que les
personnes de la diversité il ont ils ont
l'air de ce qu' on de l'air la télé puis
on sais ils se font éliminer
ouer'inrire après exact fait tu sais je
pense ça fait tout le temps comme un
cercle tu sais je
mais c'est sûr que tu sais moi je
leurais on si on si on me l'avait
proposé je serais pas allé non plus je
sais très bien que j'aurais fait une
j'aurais eu honte j'aurais été gêné puis
tu sais quand Julie est rentré à od euh
j'avis dis à ma blonde combien de jour
tu V prendre tu pense que ça va prendre
avant qu' pleure HM tu sais puis ça a
pas pris beaucoup de long ça pas été
long tu sais parce que malheureusement
c'est sûr puis il ve veut pas c'est que
si tu mets juste une personne de
diversité puis le reste et correspond
parfaitement au salur de la société même
si le gars il a dit ah oui je Seris
intéressé àter une fille il va voir les
autres à côté il va faire comme pour
pourquoi j' verelle quand il y a toutes
les filles qui sont pareiles comme ce
que tout le monde veut dans vie tu sais
fait la solution c'est juste d'OK genre
on SCP on scrape ce concept là puis on
part sur une autre base pour on on
essaie de recréer quelque chose qui fait
un peu les le fait de société que aé a
fait déjà par le passé puis on essaie de
de scraperer depuis le début en
focussant sur des trucs qui sont moins
superficiel qui sont
plus intellectuel ou ou du moins diverse
ben je pense qu' quelque chose aussi de
de
de de le fun avec je pense qu'il faut
faut se mettre rendre à l'évidence que
ce genre d'émission là c'est pour les
personnes de ce type là tu sais puis
qu'on essaie qu'on arrête de d'intégrer
de la diversité même si vous 2 minutes
je disais le contraire je trouvais qu'il
fallait mettre plus de la diversité mais
plus je pens parce que je pense pas
qu'on peut briser cette trou là avec
l'émission comm c'est ça en brainstorm
avec vous r je pense que c'est trop
encré tu sais c'est trop encré dans
patter puis c'est ça comme comme je
disais quand est parti je pense que
c'est une question de casting maintenant
où est-ce que la prod il serait
tellement content probablement d'avoir
juste du monde comme toi mainon juste du
monde qui sont drôles qui sont funny qui
sont pas dans la dans la comme moi fun
non oui oui oui oui mais genre justement
du monde qui sont pas comme le standard
d'udé là tu sais puis je su sûr qu'
serait content d'avoir juste un casting
comme ça mais imagine un casting juste
de Julie mer comment ça serait ça serait
débile mental oui sauf que je pense pas
qu' ont ce Lux là ouais avec que des
projet puis avec les personnes qui se
présentent aux auditions j'ai
l'impression que c'est ça le
problème écouteriez-vous un show comme
14 personnes puis làdedans il y a genre
cinq gros et asiatique et et noir un
handicapé ben deux handicapés peu
importe comme ça reste une téléréalité
quand même ça reste que c'est humain ça
reste des comportements qu'on aime
observer quand même on est curieux quand
même c'est juste parce qu'on est habitué
peut-être au modèle type des gens qu'on
envoie à od moi je pense que si le show
avait les mêmes attraits tu sais od
moi pas que j'ai déjà grandement écoué
au D là mais les fois que je l'écoutais
ce qui m'intéressait c'était pas genre
waouh des personnes belles selon mes
standards ce qui m'intéressait c'est
genre ok des voyages des activités funky
des locations débiles euh du drama entre
humains j'ai tu sais la raison pourquoi
je l'coute c'est pas parce que c'est du
High Candy pour moi c'est parce que
c'est le concept est cool d'accord
répondre à ta question oui je
l'écouterai je pense ou je l'aurais
écouté je l'écouterai pas plus que
j'écoute pas d mainten c'est ça mais il
y a une série qui s'appelle tu allais
parler il a
genre non mais j'allais juste dire tu
sais mais je me souviens au départ tu
sais les années Éric salv tu sais je me
souviens tu sais c'éit vraiment brandy
les plus beaux célibataires au Québec là
tu sais c'était comme
ça c'était comme ça le le le le le
concept c'était comme les plus belles
personnes ensemble ouais possiblement
que c'est sûr que ça serait fucking
intéressant puis comme différent puis le
fun avoir comme un cast vraiment
diversifié
mais l'autre jourétais on jait avant un
show dans une log pe
impor dans quelle
ville pu là
avecil avec des amis par avec des amis
quelun qui
disait comm pourquoi je mets autant cont
qu qui disait genre ça serait vraiment
malade
que il fasse un s'il faisait un haut des
queer ça serait débile ah 100 % ça
seraitement intéressant ça repiquerait
la curiosité du monde puis genre ça gen
ça rendrait ça relevant aussi mais
publicible aussi c'est ça puis là il y
avait une des personnes dans ce groupe
d'amis qui est gay puis qui disait h moi
je pense que ça nicherait vraiment le
truc puis qu'il y a bien du monde qui
débarquerait parce que a ça reste
l'émission La genre grand public par
excellence puis c'est c'est autant le
monde à Montréal mais que le monde
partout au Québec de de toutes sortes de
profils puis il y en a du monde
là-dedans que voir une émission de Just
de mon queer ouais même en 2023 mais ça
intéresse Mo je pense que d'être niche
ça peut apporter aussi beaucoup de monde
tu sais mettons on pense à Lana qui est
super quand même niche comme comme
artiste qui est devenu qui est devenu
mais c'est toujours une artiste
underground dans la c'est j que là on l'
rendu mainstream mais je Allis voir au
fait sont chaud puis j'étais là j'ai
jamais été fan d'elle moi tu sais fait
je l'ai vu puis j'ai fait
comment pas mon truc tu sa j'écouteraiis
pas ça non stop mais tout le monde
tripait sais c'est mon ami car qui m'a
dit parce que cette fill là elle pas
être mainstream vraiment fait j'ai l'IM
puis mais le monde est là pareil parce
que le monde s'identifie sûrement à elle
puis au fait qu'elle est super humaine
puis elle a vraiment ha sa fait que je
pense que un truc niche peut devenir
super mainstream quand même parce que il
y a il y a quand même beaucoup de
personnes queer de plus en plus en plus
qui l'assume puis j'avais en parl
justement d'un show qui s'appelle je
pense c'est are you the one avant
c'était juste des des personnes htéro
qui se dent un peu comme au style h h
puis eu là il ont fait une édition il y
a comme 2 ans je pense queer et moi
c'est la seule raison pourquoi je l'ai
écouté tu sais fait que j'ai écouté
aucune autre saison sauf celle-là fait
j'imagine que je suis pas la seule à
penser comme ça que tu comme ah yes
c'est un show qui nous représente tu
sais puis il y a des millions des
millions de personnes queer en fait que
je pense que ça peut être surprenant à
quel point peut-être pas la première
année mais je pense ça peut être
surprenant à quel point ça va aller
chercher des gens des curieux comme euh
les personnes qui sont queer tu sais
fait je sais pas à quel point ça serait
vraiment moins écouté c'est sûr tu sais
des des shows de télééalité Queer il y
en a plein déjà je pense là tu sais
mettons justement aux États-Unis mais tu
sais pas au Québec puis tu sais je pense
que tu sais mettons aux États-Unis il y
a tellement de monde que puis surtout
que là quand tu fais quelque chose en
anglais Mons le mon partout dans le
monde écoute ça parce que c'est comme la
langue que tout le monde comprend un peu
là tu sais je pense qu'au Québec tu sais
pour avoir
le le le le le atteindre le niveau de
popularité puis de code d'écoute de ce
genre d'émission là de genre de millions
de codes d'écoute sur un bassin de 8
million là tu sais c'est quand même
grosse proportion du monde qui l'écout
c'est dans ce coin là mais ouis non mais
mais plus maintenant tu sais mettons
mais je pense que les les plus grosses
années ça doit ressembl à ça puis
mettons les lavois ST académie les plus
grosses années c'était comme des 2.5
millions tu sais mais nous STX c'est 3
millions c'est débile on est c'est le
genre le tiers de la population du
Québec quiécoute hou fait tu sais mais
moi je suis 100 % d'accord que sera
fuing intéressant puis probblement je
l'écouterai vraiment plus que od en ce
moment parce que ça fait 2 ans que j'ai
décroché parce que je comme bon c'est
pareil au
même mais je sais je parle strictement
d'un point de vue business mettons je
sais pas si il ferait ce MOV là mais ça
serait ça serait chistement intéressant
puis mais du moins devrait faire au
moins une édition essayer une édition
moi c'est ça je me dis aussi tu sais
puis mettons un niveau financier là qui
on été capable de faire mon année à moi
avec le budget qu' avait je pense qu'
capable de faire de qui vraiment solide
en dépensant moins en voyant s'il y a de
l'intérêt puis au moins en essayant de
briser ou de faire autre chose parce que
je pense c'est le temps de faire autre
chose oui puisque reste que la une des
plus
grandes intrigue mettons de a dans les
dernières années céit CIA puis sa
queerness
avec marerie Margerie exact quicoute pas
j'ai écouté cette année là mais c'est ça
ça risque que ça l' tellement fait
couler
on a tellement parlé de ça tu sais c'est
clair céit un peu un fake mais les
filles s'en sont servis quand même puis
ça l' fonctionné tu sais fait que j'ai
personne qui a été comme choqué là on
dirait j'ai pas entendu personne faire
genre oh my god peut-être Monique en
bosse làcout toujours la B qui se passe
là ouais mais non je ve pas généraliser
mais je donnais juste un exemple au has
de quelqu'un
qui je pense que ce ce type de de drame
mettons ça attirer encore plus de monde
parce que il y a tellement de personnes
que qui s'identifient pas non plus au
c'est c'est les relations là gay c'est
pas la même chose là pour pour avoir
fait les deux c'est pas la même game
quand même tu sais puis mes amis sont
toutes gay fait que à moin que vous
voulez der mes amis là ben on est tes
amis je pense là vous êtes mes amis fait
sont pas toutes gay leses amis mais à
part deux là mes amis sont toutes gay à
part de part
deux sais
je vois bien à travers la relation aussi
que c'est pas la même chose que les
couples puis je trouve trou que ça soit
vraiment représenté puis qu'on puisse
comprendre aussi que ça ça peut ça peut
aussi dé faire bien les préjugés que de
voir deux gars qui SIM qui SIM sais à la
télévision puis de faire come on va tout
faire pour être ensemble puis au même
titre que tous les candidats
d'occupation dou qui essayent de se
matcher là des fois des fois ça prend
juste plus de représent on qui en faut
plus là mais on n'est pas encore rendu
là puis des fois je trouve aussi et ça
je v pas me faire Picher des roches je
le dis je le dis pas mais en tout cas je
le dire mais j'ai l'impression que on
prend pas toujours les bons
représentants HM qu'est-ce que tu veux
dire euh je me rappelle d'une année je
dirais pas le talk show mais le talk
show le le reality show au Québec h il y
a eu un représentant différent et il a
fait honte à une communauté quand même
et je recevais j'avais fait des stories
à l'époque où j'avais pas peur de rien
de rien dire mais
h puis les gens de la communauté
m'érivaent pour me dire oh my god tu as
tellement raison on est tellement mal on
est vraiment gêné de ça tu sais fait que
j'ai l'impression qu'on veut tellement
remplir les cotas metton qu'on va
prendre n'importe quel représentant puis
ça va pas aider à à cette communauté là
tu sais c'est comme si on prenit une
personne comme grosse puis qui allait
dire à télévision c'est vrai on veut
juste
promouvoir l'obésité nous les gros
manger on veut juste manger des sa c'est
un mauvais représentant il a le droit de
faire ce qu'il veut dans sa vie là ça me
regarde pas tu sais c'est juste que
c'est pas un bon représentant après ça
ça va perpétuer les le préjugé tu sais
c'est pas ça qu'on veut fa sa pour
n'importe quelle personne différente
avoir un représentant c'est important
mais il faut que ça soit une personne
bien choisie que ça soit la radio à Téli
peu importe sur les réseaux sociaux
aussi tu sais moi si je faisais ça sur
mes réseaux sociaux de faire la G manger
des burgers nonstop là VI l'obésité
comme je pense que la communauté des FAT
babes me dirait c'est pas ça le point là
on est pas gros arrête de de dire ça
c'est pas vrai tu sais on il y en a qui
mangent bien il y en a qui font du sport
de toute façon ça regarde personne ma
santé là la santé de personne me regarde
non plus j'ai aucun commentaire à faire
làdessus mais c'est juste que c'est ça
il faut choisir les représentants parce
qu'on veut pas que justement Monique en
bosse continue de penser que les gros
mangent juste des des burgers tu sais ou
que les noirs sont si les Mexicains sont
ça tu sais on veut pas qu' ça c'est ça
je pense juste que si on continue à
vouloir remplir des Cotos remplissons
les mais bien ouais dans l'autre sens
aussi ça doit être ça doit être lourd
des fois dur à porter tout le temps
c tu sais dans le sens que moi je me dis
jamais faut que je représente bien ma
communauté d'hommes blanc hétérosexuel
comme faut que tu sais j'essaie d'être
une bonne personne en général mais je
mets pas cette pression là de chaque
fois que tu es sur scène tu dis là je
représente les hommes htéros les hommes
Blin htéros pour tous les me blancs pour
tous les hommes blans étéros qui sont
nés dans une classe privilégiée tu sais
celle est pour vous oh yeah puis tu sais
j'imagine qu'il y a du monde là-dedans
aussi
que j'imagine qu' du monde là-dedans qui
ont pas néement envie d'être le
porte-parole pu ont juste envie d'être
d'être eux-mêmees avec leur qualité
leurs défaut puis de sil se retrouvent
devant une caméra de juste être puis tu
sais mais tu sais moi au début quand
j'ai commencé sur les réseaux sociaux
moi c'était jamais dans mon intention de
commencer à devenir parole de
d'antiossantigrossophobie ou tout ça
puis j'ai j'ai juste existé au début tu
sais je suis comme une personne bien
simple puis mné j'avais fait pour moi
j'avais fait un shooting en lingerie
puis j'avais hésité longtemps à pourer
ce shooting là puisent je l'ai fait puis
là c'est là que ça j'ai comme eu un
déclic parce que les gens m'écrivait oh
my god grâce à toi c'est la première
fois que je me regarde dans le miroir
grâce vraiment c'est c'est eux qui ont
fait le travail mais tu sais genre je me
je me regarde dans le miroir je me suis
prise en photo je me je me su je j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser plus à ça puis
j'ai fait comme ok c'est vrai qu'on a
besoin d'avoir de la représentation tu
sais puis après ça je me suis mis ça sur
les épaules je voulais faire des des
captions des PO vraiment qui limite
politique là tu sais que j'étais comme
on a le droit d'exister ouais activiste
c'est mieux que politique que limite
politique mais à quoi que être gros dans
une société comme ça c'est politique tu
sais c'est un statement quand même là tu
sais c'est pas que j'ai choisi nécement
statement que tu choisis de faire mais
fait c'est ça fa j'ai commencer comme ça
puis momenté je me suis dit quand j'ai
vu justement les activistes qui
arrivaient puis que eux il s
travaillaient fort là-dessus tu il
disait beaucoup d'affaires puis ça
devenait politique j'ai gen fait oh moi
c'est pas ma place moi je suis un peu un
clown qu' des affaires à dire une fois
de temps en temps qui pense beaucoup
mais qui partage pas tout tu sais puis
je veux y rester comme ça je veux juste
vivre tu sais puis y a plein de gens que
je suis sur les réseaux sociaux qui font
juste vivre puis qui m'inspirent pareil
sais puis mon but c'est pas d'inspirer
personne non plus mais on a vu ça avec
le black Liv matter qui a un influenceur
Jessica prudentio qui elle
assez tu sais quand quand il y a eu ça
toutes les les les les influenceurs ont
commencé à mettre le spotlight sur elle
aller suivre j prudentio
elle a la réponse à vos questions tu
sais puis elle pas com du monde qui nous
ont proposé ça aussi qui nous dirigeait
là mais c'est ça mais tu sais elle a pas
demandé ça elle elle a pas demandé à
avoir ce fardeau là de devoir ex elle la
faisait juste faire sa son truc exact là
tout le monde écrivait mais là j'ai le
droit de faire ça je de dire ça si je
fais ça non je peux faire ça et comme
mais mon dieu c'est tout du labor que
vous me demandez de faire là je suis pas
payé pour faire ça je comprends que
c'est pour ma communauté sauf que je
veux juste vivre continuer de vivre ma
vie tu sais mais elle a fait quand même
une coupe d'affaires qu'elle a essayé
d'instruire le monde d'éduquer les gens
mais elle le payé aussi avec sa santé
mentale tu sais on a vu ça à travers les
dernières années elle a commencé à
consulter puis tout ça puis
là ça va mieux mais reste que ça lu a
fait ça causé des traumas à cette
personn là là tu sais de à tous les
jours se faire demander des questions
par ces personnes blanches là qui se
posent des questions Google qu ouais
alleer googler là aller lire des livres
elle a fait ce travail là pourquoi vous
le feriez pas sa ce travail là parce qu'
est noir qui est né avec tout le le
background pu cé tout qu'est-ce qui se
passe n sais est allé étudier exact est
allé étudier tu allé lire est aller
s'informer fait la même chose ça vous
intéresse vraiment h faites-le sais
ouais là c'est vous vous faites vous
écrivez comme ça pour pour vous dédoiner
de penser certaines affaires ou pour pas
avoir à faire les les les recherches
mais elle elle a vécu ça tu sais puis
c'est fucking de la merde moi j'ai j'ai
vu dernièrement elle en parlait puis
j'étais comme oh my god j'avais pas
pensé à ça à quel point elle a dû se
faire bombarder parce que c'était des
dizaines et des dizaines terrible
pendant toutite après George Floyd dans
le fond tout tu parti là ça devait être
terrible sa plateforme tu imagine tu
fais couper une jambe aujourd'hui là
puis là tout le monde tout le monde qui
qui toutes les handicapés m'écrivent ou
toutes les personnes m'écrivent comment
respecter un handicapé exact les
personnes qui ont leurs deux jambes
qu'est-ce que je devrais faire dans mon
building là pour faciliter les gens
c'est commecr t recherches comment tu te
sens de puis qu' te reste juste une
jambe quel soulier je devrais acheter
est-ce que on peut se faire rembourser
un soulier sur deux tu sais metton tu
fais écrire ça nonstop tu es comme merci
de me rappeler à tous les jours que je
suis différent tu sais c'est lourd là
pour pour les personnes comme ça j que
c'est c'est un exemple il y en a plein
qui ont vécu ce genre d'affair là tu
sais même juste pour les grosses
personnes il y en a qui m'écrivent des
affaires moi en tant que que personne m
enant qu'aliier nana est-ce que tu la
faire est-ce que tu la faire je peux-tu
dire ça comment je dis à mon ami que que
je me sens ballonné quand j'ai fini de
manger mais tu dis pas las femme ta
gueule tu es ballonné tu es ballonné
soit ballonné dans ton côté là pas
besoin de le dire là sais moi les
personnes m c'est vraiment les grandes
questions de la vie ça genre mon AM une
personne grosse moi je suis une personne
balonné et là je suis ballonné mais je
veux pas la faire se sentir grosse non
mais de dire comme j'ai trop mangé parce
que moi ça m'est arrivé plein de fois
d'être avec mes amis puis oh my god tu
une grosse vache là je viens de
manger h tu es comme ah fait que tu une
grosse vache à 120 livres moi je quoi
sais un troupeau je sais pas tu sais je
trouve ça vraiment comme mais tu as pas
besoin de m'écrire pour pour me le
demander fait juste utiliser le gros le
gros bonens sa barouette ou au pire des
pire des PIR Google si jamais il do
avoir des vidéos sur YouTube déjà des
personnes qui ont voulu faire ça tu sais
je sais que c'est pas méchant qu'est-ce
quand qui m'écrit pour me demander ça
mais il y a pas une affaire puis moi moi
tu sais je à vraiment plus petite
échelle mais des fois je me fais poser
des questions sur mett l'entraînement tu
du monde qui m'écrivve en DM puis il y a
pas une chose que moi je peux
t'apprendre qui va pas arriver dans le
top 2 des recherches sur Google c'est
écrit exactement ce que tu viens de
m'écrire à moi sur Google exactement ta
question sur Google dans le top 2 il
c'est des meilleure réponse que ce que
moi je peux te donner genre c'est sûr
moi je suis loin d'être un coach je suis
loin d'être un nutritionniste je suis
loin genre écrit dans Google moi je t'ai
dit tu me donnerais des trucs tu me
donnerais des trucs c'est comm c'est
quoi les trucs que tu veux c'est comm ça
mais je sais pas pourquoi on fait ça tu
sais je m'inclu làdedans parce que je
l'ai faite avec toi mais quoi que je je
suis déjà faite mais ça se peut très
bien que jeai déjà fait dans dans le
passé c'est c'est normal de vouloir
aussi interagir avec des g tu sais je
veux dire toi tu m'écris moi ça va me
faire plaisir de discuter avec toi ça on
est amis un de tes seul amis
et mais mais tu sais ça va me faire
plaisir de discuter avec toi mais c'est
juste quand tu connais pas la personne
mais en même temps je comprends aussi
l'autre point de vue de faire genre
cette personne là je la suis je la
trouve inspirante je fais confiance sur
ce qu'elle va dire tu sais puis ça m'a
je veux dire continue à m'écrire la gang
si vous m'écoutez parce que j'en reçois
pas des milliers ça me fait plaisir de
répondre à ceux que que je reçois mais
mais quand même le pointant que tout se
trouve sur Google oui on n pas la
référence de rien sa moi j'ai pas étudié
en activisme en gros antigrossophobie
tout le ça se peut que ce que je veux
dire c'est comment moi je me sens puis
comment je me sens avec la situation
mais c'est pas la vérité absolue tu sais
puis ceux qui sont une référence
écrivezleur encore moins parce que eux
autres qui ont étudié pour devenir une
référence puis leur temps puis leur
connaissance doit être monétisé tu sais
fait que genre écrivez pas à un
nutritionniste des questions de
nutrition
par quei s il ais ça puis il va pas don
sair gratement quelqu'un du cas par cas
sur Instagram mais c'est ça on va payer
le nutritionniste mais pourquoi on
aurait pas payé quelqu'un racisé pour
justement nous éduquer làdessus là on lu
demande de faire du travail grtis sur
les le travail qu'elle a fait ellemême
tu sais fait je trouvais ça vraiment au
début j'étais comme
ah une personne ou deux il doivent
écrire mais elle elle raconte que à quel
point il y avait du monde qui écrivait
ça devait être fou c'est c'est ça puis
avec avec le recul je me dis ça devait
être traumatisant c'est vraiment le mot
sais moi si à tous les jours j'ai des
micro traumatismes comme chaque fois que
tuouvres ton cellulaire chaque fois que
tuouves des notif des messages non lu
c'est ça fait que j'imagine même pas
elle comment qu'elle a dû bper puis que
je dis elle mais il do avoir à ce
momentl il devit avoir des centaines
milliers de personnes noires qui se
faisaient écrire pour savoir qu'est-ce
que je dois faire qu'est-ce que je dois
dire qu'est-ce que je dois dire je pas
éduquer va t'éduquer tu sais mais au
début quand elle a commencé à dire ça
j'étais comme oh mais là tu veux que le
monde arrête de de place mais c'est sais
au début j'étais comme mais après ça
après 3 4 semaines 5 semaines 6 semaines
des années là je fais comme ok là doit
tabarouette puis aussi c'est
qu'essentiellement elle faisait juste
exister avant ça genre puis elle voulait
juste continuer à
faire ça do fu une personne ça quand
même ouais euh on va revenir au au début
de la conversation au début de l'énorme
parenthèse puis ça va nous permettre de
de de faire une coupure vers ton podcast
ah ou parce que tu nous racontais que là
tu avais dit à ta blonde ok on se voit
on voit personne 10 jours avant on se
teste puis après ça on se voit oh
r aussi moi aussi j'ai comme fait ok
ouvrez la parenthèse puis on va y
revenir puis là une heure plus tard on y
revient je suis pas diagnostiqué encore
mais pensez-vous que j'ai un Tdh euh non
ah mon Dieu je pense pas ah ouais vous
êtes les seules personnes qui dis ben tu
as pas l'air de partir dans les places
tu sais des fois le monde en TDA ils
vont juste pas écouter ce que tu dis
puis ils vont partir dans une place
complètement externe c'est pas
l'expérience que j'ai maintenantéout
mais j'écoute vraiment j'écoute vraiment
sauf que mais tu es pas parti dans une
tangente on on t'a suivi là pu sais tu d
ah faut que ça soit le T pour trouble ou
ouais ouais ouais je sais pas n'importe
quoi non mais tu sais dans le sens que
pour
tabarnac ah
oui mais euh tu sais tu sais moi j'ai
j'ai moi je je pensais que j'étais des
ha aussi là puis j'ai fait les les les
des tests là neuropsie toutes les kit là
genre finalement c'est une douance avec
un extrêmement élevé cuit
mais la moyen ah ouais tuas fait un test
de cuit tout non non mais c'est pas un
test de ben c'est un test de trou ça
j'aurais jamais cru ça me fait rire
c'est j non mais com qu'urit nos petits
hommes blancs là quand Mme
hérosexuel avec un CU plus élevé que la
moyenne P
piti mais mais c'est ça tu sais ça
mesure c'est comme plein de tests gen
gen des C des tests de mémoire puis là
après ça fait comme ton genre de profil
justement tu comme plusieurs types
d'intelligence rent dans le
triangle gen puis là tu comme des desis
dans les pourcentiles de
C dans les pourcent per percentil
percentil percentil puis là bref moi
j'étais rentré là convaincu que j'avais
le téléage puis moi aussi j'étais
convaincuu ah ouais il est déjà sorti du
vestiaire avec juste une botte
ouais ouais non mais tu sais gen je
quelqu'un qui par ses affaires qui tombe
dans l'une qui tu sais qui est un peu
mêlé qui je m'envois quelque part c'est
sûr je me trompe de chemin tu sais tout
ça
puis était comme tu sais oui tu as
certaines difficultés mais genre pour je
diagnostique un trouble puis que tu as
besoin de médicentation c'est comme un
autre niveau là quand même là tu sais
puis
genre tu es comme moi je vois je vois ça
puis je me dis pas ce gars là mais il y
a plusieurs formes il y a plusieurs ça
se présente il y a plusieurs symptômes
plusieurs traits puis ouais dans S tu
peux avoir des traits sans être
diagnostiqué non non c'est ça mais moi
ça c'est pas que ça gâche ma vie mais tu
sais je pas diagnostiqué mais ma psie
dernièement m'a dit il faut vraiment que
tu consultes pour ça ça pe que tu le
sois tu sais il faut vraiment que tu
consultes tu as des ouais des petites
lacunes là ouais puis eu pu c'est ça
mais tu sais je pense pas que c'est
quelque chose qui nuit à ma vie trop
trop Sauf que je le sens je l'ai senti
quand quand les responsabilité on
embarqué j'ai fait comme au P et là je
traî la patte mais j'ai jamais eu besoin
de faire des gros efforts tu sais moi à
l'école ça allait super bien j'avais
toujours des bonnes notes fait que
j'étudiais pas j'avais des bonnes notes
fa j' été confronté vraiment au fait que
il fallait que je rel fois la même
phrase pour que ça me rentre dans tête
puis aujourd'hui qu quand je lis quelque
chose je suis
commez des Tex jeis plus capable on
dirait puis mais vois ple d'aaire qui
qui me ralentissent mais ça ça fait
partie justement des signes dans le sens
que elle la neuropsyque qui m'a checké à
checker voulait avoir mes bulletins du
primaire puis tu sais que toutes les
avec les commentaires des profs non
parce que dit tu peux pas tu deviens pas
Tdh tu
l'IS si tu l'IS tu l'IS quand tu étais
jeune puis checker ça puis tu sais il y
a des signes qui qui trompent pas là tu
sais quand tu étais puis tu sais
justement checkant ça aussi puis avec
les tests c'est comme quand tu étais
jeune je veux dire qui peut-être que tu
étais dans l'une des fois mais tu sais
tu avais pas de difficulté à l'école tu
avais pas de difficulté de concentration
en fait que tu sais fait tu sais ça
c'est peut-être un autre signe que c'est
la vie d'adulte Mo tout je parle pour
moi pu on fait on ouvre nos parenthèses
mais on va faire plus courte là tu sais
moi la vie d'adulte je pense c'est juste
la vie de travailleur autonome que c'est
comme
tu sais quand tu vas au primaire au
secondaire au sjet la vie est comme
organisée pour toi tu sais comme tu vas
à l'école de telle heure à telle heure
TU la fin de semaine tu vas pas à
l'école non pu c'est comme que tuarrive
dans vraie vie puis là c'est comme tu as
été habitué de toute ta vie d'avoir une
structure puis là c'est comme tout d'un
coup à moins que tuas une job 9 à 5 ce
qui est pas mon cas la structure c'est
toi qu' faut qu' fasse puis ça c'est
quand
même
plus difficile qu'on pense tu sais dans
le sens que j'ai été moi une bonne
partie de ma vingtaine à être comme
vraiment volo à travailler un peu
n'importe quand des fois jusqu'à 2h du
matin me lever tard non
toute une avant-midi sur sur mon ordi à
rien faire après ça travailler puis là
c'est relativement nouveau dans ma vie
que comme je r trouve un genre de
stabilité comme dans le temps que
j'allais à l'écoleok Ben me lever à peu
près vers telle heure travailler de
telle heure à telle heure puis le soir
rentrer à la maison avec ma blonde me
faire souper on écoute une petite
émission on se couche puis là c'est
comme ah ok je retrouve un genre de
structure on dirait que tout d'un coup
il y a plein d'affaires de mon supposé
TDA que je pensais qui sont plus là qui
sont vraiment moins là juste parce que
j'ai ma routine que j'ai mes mes
habitudes ben oui c'est important même
quand tu t d'avoir une routine c'est
encore plus important d'avoir une roue
en encore plus important mais tu sais
c'est important pour tout le monde je
pense que n'importe qui qui qui qui a un
horaire atypique ou qui a une vie
atypique il va avoir des genres de tras
TDO juste parce que c'est on est on on
fonctionne mieux organisé ça c'est
certain
merci cé mon Histor chose certaine m si
toi tu as pas de TDA ouais
euh puis que moi j'en ai pas non plus
nos cerveaux fonctionnent quand même
vraiment différemment tu sais on
fonctionne vraiment différemment fait il
y en a un nous deux qui est pas
neuronormatif mais ça êre to parce que
TR 4 He de sport par jour
là on est peut-être même les deux on l'
peut-être pas tu sais oui mais tu sais
je les deux on est c'est après ça
normatif c'est comme c'est quoi la norme
c'est qui qui non mais je pense tu une
personne sur trois qui serait neuronorma
neur neurotypique euh ouais neurotypique
ouais il neuratypique neurotypique ok ok
ben qui qui est comme un un un genre de
de cerveau qui fonctionne ouaisou ouais
genre standard m parce mettons le
graphique de la de la de la cloche là tu
sais ouais tu sais tu tout le monde dans
le milieu que c'est le le la grosse
partie de la cloche tout le monde
extrême on est
peut-être cé à une extrémité de la norme
mais on est pas non plus un extrême
extrême tu saison est quand même
différent mais on est pas non plus
complètement socialement mésadapté mais
pas madapté je P êes
madapt qume mais je veux dire
socialementè diff mais je pense que dans
TDA aussi il y a des gens que qui ont
l'hyper focus sais puis pu je me bat pas
pour vous faire croire que j'tais des
vraiment pas là enendant de moi comme il
y a une partie de moi qu' sait depuis
que tu suis toute jeune que j'ai que je
suis pas neurotypique mou
puis euh j'ai l'impression qu'il y a des
moments tu sais où est-ce que je suis
vraiment focus focus je suis vraiment
concentré je vous mais sais moi il faut
que je fasse de quoi aussi quand vous
parlez faut que je fasse de quoi faut
que je pense à d'autre chose parce que
sinon si je trop focus mé j'écoute plus
tu sais fait qu'il faut que soit que je
joue avec mes affaires que je boive que
je fasse il faut que je me stimule tu
sais puis euh si j'ai le si je suis
concentré puis tu as le malheur de me
déranger de un ça pète tout puis de deux
je suis en tabarnach ah ouais ouais des
fois ma blonde je suis dans le bureau je
travaille à rentre pour câin plus je
suis
genre
câin on fait un câlin plus je suis
contente sais si elle faisait pas comme
je Seris tout le temps comme ouais ouais
mais c'est ça j'ai cette capacité là à
être vraiment focus focus focus il y a
rien qui peut me déranger puis quand il
y a une enant qui me dérange réellement
là ça fout tout si je vois j'ai un appel
après ça je vaisêre sur mon cel pendant
une heure il y a aussi la tendance à
procrastiner ce c'est une ENF que j'ai
toujours toujours fait mes parents il
fallait qu'il fasse mes mes gros projets
au au au primire fallait qu'il m'aide 3h
du matin là à tout faire nos tu sais les
les gros affaires qu'il faut faire des
gros cartons j'avais préparé ma dans ma
tête tout était là j'allais pouvoir dire
moi je me débrouille tu sais oralement
je me débrouillis j'inventais
j'aiimovise tu sais ça me dérange pas
mais là quand il fallait avoir du
support le visuel puis j'avais oublié de
faire ça puis j'étais comme oh maman
j'ai oublié de faire ça fa que là ma
mère était comme tabnac all acheter
toutes les affaires pu pendant la la
soirée jusqu'à la nuit elle faisait avec
moi les affaires puis le Lain je me
réveillais puis c'était là tu sais puis
je fais parti avec mes trucs tu sais
mais ma mère elle m'a sauvé une coupile
de fois là F j'ai pas étudié t affaire
mais c'est ça tu une chance nos parents
on on eu cette chance moi trop sauvé je
pense que c'est pour ça que j'ai
certaines lacunes dans ma vie que tu as
été la une MRE trop une mère qui tuas
quand même trop donné là vous connaissez
depuis combien de temps longsis qu'on a
5e année 4e année c'est ça vous
connaissez vraiment une grande partie de
votre passé là ouais oua ouais vraiment
mais ouais Mar Jose
te couveré longtemps quand même ouais
vraiment puis tu sais justement elle
comme elle vraiment c'est vraiment
dégueu à dire mais genre tu quand
j'étais
jeune je me ramassais pas on se
ramassait pas ma mère genre ramassait
sais pour tout le monde faisait pas
notre lavage faisait jamais à manger on
faisait rien fa que là j'arrive adulte
j'ess comme faire M faut tout faire ça
c'est ça un adul Cook ça t'as sauvé la
vie là toi pendant un bout ça a vraiment
été bon pour toi ouais ouais oua ouais
quand qu'on habitaé ensemble puis
c'était avant que tu commences cookit là
ouais cétait c'est genre peut-être une
journée sur deux ouais un burger vég
avec des légumes des légumes congelés
stetimés puis genre sinon c'était des
boles de vctor genre c'était ça mon
alimentation on dirait que tu par de
quelqu'un qui vient d'arriver en appart
pour la première fois sa vie on avait 30
ans vous avez quel âge là 30 302 ok pas
si longtemps que ça non ouais mais je
peux comprendre ça moi quand je ça me
tentait pas de faire la cuisine surtout
quand tu es tout seul tu sais h je m
souvent des BES de riz des
saucisses r sauciss avec du ketchup de
PA mais juste du riz blanc avec sauc
ouais fa pa finalement dis ça genre
comme c'est mon genre de soup r sa avec
du ketchup
oh non des ch à dog ah ok ah ouais mais
tu ptit morceau ketchup en BL je
comprends pourquoi c'est bon c'est
fucking bon tu sais je mangeais ça puis
ou je mangeais des toastes sa j'étais
2000 dollar de
uber ça voy
avec mais je peux
comprendrei ce niveau aussi chez
ménage
faage éta faén ensemble on a eu
plusieurs à cause de
ça c'est la
chose
l'irritant moi c'est c'est mon irritant
m en couple ça l' toujours été mon
irritant puis moi je me ramasse quand
même beaucoup mais je suis même
peut-être anal sur certaines affaires là
tu sais genre il faut que les trucs
soient d'une certaine façon puis ça ça a
toujours été un iritant dans toutes mes
relations où est-ce que c'est comme
genre je suis plus capable de me
chicaner pour ça genre je suis plus
capable qu'on parle de ça genre on va
prendre une femme de ménage juste même
si on a pas les moyens de on va faire
quelqu'un va venir faire le ménage chez
nous ça a pas de sens tu sais que c'est
drôle comment dans 100 % des couples il
y en a un qui anal sur le ménage puis
l'autre qui se laisse traîner c'est tout
le temps ça c'est vrai c'est r qu' a
deux personnes qui sont fucking genre on
récure aujourd'hui c'est notre journée
plaisir sais puis puis la personne que
que ça va faire chier le plus c'est la
personne qui est tale parce que l'autre
ça va pas l'autre faire tal me parler de
ça tout le
temps je pensais à une joke qui était
éventuelle ben une joke éventuelle je
pensais à une affaire qui est drôle à
c'est ton prochain numéro stand prochain
stand up mon prochain standup comic
c'est comme dans vie il y a deux
personnes il y a deux types de personnes
puis il y a un type de personne qui sait
même pas que c'est ce type de personne
là mais l'autre type de personne va
exactement savoir de quoi je parle ceux
qui laissent le cover sur
l'humus le petit plastique mais il faut
prement que tu manges de l'humus fait ça
pe aucun peut mais genre ou le yogourt
ou parce que il y a du monde qui ouvre
toi tu fais ça tu ouvres le pot du m
avec le plastique mais tu la laisse le
cover de plastique dessus fait là il
devient tout crotté ça rentre dedans là
ça rentre dedans pu là quand tu rouves
l'UMUS c'est comme faut que tu trendes
les doigts dans l'UMUS pour enlever la
FO c'est débile faire ça genre c'est
débile faire ça même sur la SAF que le
monde qui le font il s'en rend pas
compte qui font ça genre ils font juste
ouvrir le mus ont tout le temps ouvert
ouvert le mususe de même moi ça me fait
capoter chaque fois j'arrive dans un
frigo puis il y a le papier du mus qui
trem dans l'US c'est débile puis quand
j'en parle au monde autour de moi il y a
vraiment le monde qui font genre des
coupes d'amis main il a quelqu'un qui
fait ah moi j'ai jamais remarqué ça pu
le son sa blonde c'est comme mais oui
parce que toi tu fais ça exa c'est ça
c'est le même profil genre il est tout
le temps et de moi chez nous genre ma
blonde peut pas relaxer avant que tout
soit clean ouais moi je suis comme on
relaxe on fer ça tantô ma BLONDME aussi
puis c'est tout le temps ça puis tu sais
moi ma blonde c'est genre la plus belle
relation au monde genre ça va fucking
bien mais s'il y a une affaire qui peut
avoir un minimum de friction c'est le
mage ouais mais moi avant je poign
vraiment avec elle à cause que tu sais
mettant elle mettait elle va en tabarnac
ça mais elle mettait genre mettait ses
Bobet sales sur la
tableiment non mais tu sais elle sortait
de la douche elle prenait une serviette
pour ses cheveux une serviette pour son
corps pu elle arrivait elle les laissa
un boule sous le lit à terre à terre
vraiment là puis là
s'habillit son linge à terre puisé il y
avait une pile à côté de son barord de
lit mais elle marchait dessus pour aller
se coucher puis le panier est là comment
tu vis comment tu vis le panier il est
là le lit est là son linge il est là fa
juste ouais c'est ça au lieu de le
mettre là tu tu mets un pied à côté dans
Pourquoi puis mé je ramassé tous les
jours puis j'ai juste fait je va plus le
faire elle va se rendre compte Mané que
c'est chiant marcher sur son linge
mouillé à tous les jour ouais jamais
jamais rendu compte non c'est ça la FO C
test là ça marche jamais s'en est foutu
je va voir combien de temps ça peut
traîner ça traînne à l'infini puis 100 %
puis elle m'a juste dit on a juste pas
les mêmes standards j'éis comme c'est
vrai ça c'est sûr que c'est vrai mais sa
mère elle a toujours ramassé mais
objectivement mes standards sont
peut-être mieux que tes standard mais tu
sais elle est
mtenanttivement mais maintenant là je
dis je dis bravo parce que elle s'est
vraiment amélioré par des fois je me
levais le samedi matin parceelle se
vraiment plus tard que moi la fin de
semaine main fait que là je me levais le
samedi matin je commencé à faire le
ménage je m'entraînais ménage super tôt
puis là elle se levait 2 heures après ça
faisait 2h je fais du ménage plus là
elle se levait plus je voyais qu'elle
laissait la porte un peu ouverte de
l'armoire puis aprenait je sais pas moi
jeetis pas t l'aire puis j'étais comme h
non non non non non non non non puis là
ça gâchait toute ma journée mais c'est
ça là moi tu vois moi j'étais où est-ce
que tu es là mais là au fil du temps
puis au fil de comment des fois ça me
rendait misérable dans des relations il
fallu qu'ener je fasse just ok faut que
tu changes un peu parce que tu peux
demander à l'autre personne de changer
briser un un briser quelque chose ça
fait 25 ans que tu fais dans ta vie là
c'est tof en Christ oui dep ma blonde me
amélioré là y a un chemin sauf qu'il y a
un chemin à faire des deux bar j'ai
l'impression parce qu' amené tu sais
justement comme elle on peux-tu pas
faire la vaisselle la seconde que c'est
prêt metton gen ouais ok oui là je suis
capable de faire ça avant j'étais avant
je faisais la vaisselle avant de manger
mon assiette ouais c'est c'estis genre
je je l'avais tout avant même de pouvoir
m'asseoir pour être bien pour manger
fallait je lave toute sais et elle mais
des fois quand maintenant est rendu je
va prendre ton terme anal sur la cuisine
c'est sa cuisine il faut que ça soit
propre fait elle c'est vraiment son
département là c'est elle qui fait la
cuisine fait que là je mange puis elle
elle mange vraiment pas beaucoup à
manger qure bouché de son repas cuisine
elle comme fait queelle mange quatre
bouché pu là elle se lève automatique
elle jette ses affaires ou elle met dans
un Power pe importe puis après ça lave
commence à laver mais moi des fois j'ai
tuasas pas commencé Mang ou j'ai pas
fini de manger puis
ouais non ça c'est pas bon fa que là tac
je finis de manger don boucher tac
commence à laver un moment le fun on
mange on partage on on mange le plus
possible puis on mais c'est ça elle veut
que ça soit clean quand qu' a fini de
faire à manger quand a manger c'est
clean sauf que on prend pas le temps de
bien de manger ensemble de vraiment
discuter le kit prièement elle veut pas
que je l'aide à faire la cuisine
elle déteste ça qu' dans sa cuisine fait
que là
elle fait le repas ser ça cœur parce que
elle l' toute cuisiné ça de manger pu
c'est bizarre ouais je t' dis ben mange
pas beaucoup mange pas beaucoup là mais
le fait qu' le fait de l'avoir fait
pendant 1 heure ça sent tu l'as dans le
nez tu le long tu manges ça comme oh j'
curé déjà c'est comme si le fait de le
sentir elle l'avait mangé tu sais OK
puis fait c'est ça fait en tout cas
c'est juste j'ai la misère à finir mon
mon assiette qu'elle a déjà enlevé mais
ça c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment c'est amélioré parce que
jusqu qu'elle sache
c'est est vraiment
incroyable ma ça r des qualités
exceptionnelle c'est céit ça le problème
cétait le le hic ce qui nous ramène à
votre de c quoi date la première fois
après une semaine à pas voir personne
face pu ce qui est drôle c'est qu'en
plus ma m'avait dit qu'elle aimait pas
FaceTime tiender en fait c'était une
soirée chez Rosalie il devait être
environ 7h
puis puis c'est ça fait que là Rosalie
me d on se met sur 2 on swipe puis ce
que j'ai fait je pourquoi pas puis moi
laffire c'est que j'ai été adepte là des
des réseaux de rencontes pendant des
années ou j'en ai toutes mes dates sur
des réseaux de rencontre j'ai j'en ai eu
des dizaines et des dizaines puis
c'était juste le réseau de rencontre
puis là j'avais décidé d'enlever ça pour
je sais pas quelle raison sement une de
mes j'ai j'ai dû frappé une vraiment une
dernière date horrible fuck off là fait
que là Rosa me dit on fait ça je fais ah
ben pourquoi pas fait que là je me je me
suis remis tinder puis on s pas ensemble
puis ça a pas pris longtemps que moi je
m'étais mis gofé puis là j'ai vu ma
blonde pu jeai swipé puis je me suis dit
je suis clairement pas dans sa ligue
puis 10 minutes après elle m'avait on
avait un match P commencé à parler puis
je voyais que c'était la seule qui
comprenait un peu mais pas mon humour ça
prend pas un B comprend mon humour mais
dans le sens que tu sais j'étais un peu
sarcastique puis elle elle comprenait
puis elle embarquait là-dedans puis h
elle l'essayait pas elle le faisait tu
sais des fois je parleis avec du monde
que j'ai souvent trouvé euh plate parce
que tu sais il comprenait pas trop puis
il embarquait pas puis ce qu' essayait
de faire c'était comme ah je c'est
gênant tu sais fait que ça m'attirait
pas tu sais mais h et elle elle a tous
embarqué fait en tout cas on a full
connecté on on n arrêtait pas de se
parler puis elle ' elle s'annonçait
comme une personne full distante puis
don bien ténébreuse puis puis
mystérieuse puis qu'elle voulait plus tu
sais c'était tout de suite dès le départ
c'était comme tu viendras pas chez nous
tout de suite je viendrai pas chez vous
mes amis c'est ma priorité euh je dors
pas chez personne puis personne dors
chez moi puis j'is comme ok dit je pas
de FaceTime parfait ok fait que là ça
prè une journée qu'on en FaceTime dans
le fond on se parle pas puis on se d
c'est ça c'est ça match puis on parle
plus c'est ça mais elle cherchait juste
les plaisirs de la chair
puis fait que c'est ça fait que là
finalement ça a pris de jours qu' temp
FaceTime ça a
pris on se Tex tous les jours nonstop là
tu sais il y av pas de break là c'était
pas m à me dit faut que j'organise la
fait à mon ami on a des affaires à
construire fa je te laisse pour la
journée je ok parfait bonne journée 2
minutes après regarde j'ai fait ça j'ai
fait ça elle arrêtait pas et moi de même
puis c'est ça puis après ça ça pris une
semaine qu'on qu'on se rendontre puis là
est venu dormir chez Rosa puis après ça
est resté genre pendant elle dormait
tous les jours chez nous ouais puis'
ouais ouais c'est ça elle tout tout ce
qu'elle m'a dit c'est la BCH exact ça
pris une semaine avant que je rencontre
ses amis c'est toujours bon dire que tu
es distant non non mais c'est c'est vrai
dans le sens que c'est probablement ce
qu'elle voulait être ce qu' a planifiait
être c'est qui qui a étaé avec les
autres fill qui a rencontré avant moi
peutêtre aussi tu sais jeux dire moi
quand j'ai rencontré ma blonde j'étais
comme dans une phase de comme ouais non
mais tu sais je veux savoir on en
reparle non mais non mais jeéis juste
dans une phase de genre une pH de casé
une phase plaisir de la chair puis là
j'éis comme genre on peut dire
anal
an non non mais tu sais c'est ça puis je
m'en allais jeis Allis chez eux puis
j'étais pas en mode comme je je
recherche une relation une blonde mais
c'est comme des fois tu es juste quand
tu tombes sur quelqu'un des fois ça ça
quand tu attends le moins c'est là qui
comme qui se passe de quoi puis que tu
dis finalement ce que je pensais ce que
que je voulais ou ce que je pensais où
je t'ai rendu ben là c'est comme ça ça
provoque autre chose voulez-vous savoir
notre première date oui s'il vous plaît
c'était j'avais moi j'avais un chat lion
Paul qui me rendait vraiment je l' eu 5
ans puis la dernière année il me rendait
allergique de ouf j'étais vraiment un
truc de ouf j'ai genre ça pas de bon
sens puis je suis asthmatique plus ça
ressortait tout mon asthme mais ce que
j'avais pas compris c'est parce que
j'avais eu la covid fait c'est mon ASME
qui est ressorti à cause de la covid et
non mon chat puis là j'avais réussi à
trouver une femme qui voulait un animal
de compagnie elle avait la sclérose en
plaque puis était tout temps toute seule
puis elle m'a dit ah ben moi j'aimerais
ça avoir un chat tu sais j'étais comme
ah ben tu sais ça pourrait l'aider puis
on pas est vraiment affueux tout ça fait
que là je la porte là-bas puis une
semaine et demi après elle m'écrit pour
me dit ça va être impossible genre lion
Paul il zingne partout il Pise dans mon
lit pu j'tais comm mon Dieu jamais vécu
ça avec mon chat tu sais fait qu' était
pas content d'être là fait que là
j'avais dit à ma blonde ben marie
piierre à l'époque j'avais dit il faut
que j' chercher mon chat lundi ah oui
dit on se voit lundi pu je suis comme ah
il faut que j'aille rechercher mon chat
lundi à avec toi je comme c'est la
première fois que vous allez voir comme
c'est une première date de merde quand
même que tu à chercher mon chat chez une
femme fait que là dit ben non ça me fait
plaisir fait que là elle débarqué le
lundi soir puis l'ffaire c'est que au
qu'elle débarqué chez nous je sais pas
êché que j'ai ça en tout cas première
affire qu' qu'elle a fait c'est qu'on
s'est frenché tout de suite ah ouais
hein elle est sorti son ch est arrivé
devant moi m belle P m French mais
est-ce que vous aviez une genre de tu
sais dans vos text dans vos FaceTime il
av un peu de séduction physique làou on
parlait pas de de sexe vraiment tu sais
ma BL n pas comme ça puis moi j'étais de
même juste avec les gars tu sais h
j'avais pas ça avec les filles j'avais
j'avais fréquenté fréquentouillé
quelques filles avant ma blonde puis ça
tombait pas là puis j'appréciais ça
parce que je me dénaturais vraiment avec
les gars euh jeais donc faire plaisir tu
sais puis eu puis c'est ça fa mais quand
qu'on s'est vu c'était pas c'était pas
nécessairement comme on baise maintenant
c'était vraiment juste comme ça fait une
semaine qu'on qu'on se parle à tous les
jours nonstop on fait partie de notre
quotidien tu sais à à rentrer travailler
le matin après 3h de sommeil parce qu'on
faitam jusqu'à 5h du matin tu sais fait
que c'est épuisant ça ah 100 % ça te
fuck un cycle quand même c'est épuisant
ouais fait là c'est le fun oui
c'estmi parler jusqu'à 3h du matin là je
déteste ça ah
oua moi ma blande les premières des là
genre don arrivé genre à 7h le soir
comme je puis on a jé jusqu'à 4h du
matin nonstop premère c'est ça puis gen
elle a travaill le lendemain à 8 9h là
tu sais aujd'hui 11h aujourd'hui les
deux on se couche à 11h puis on est full
genre mon sommeil c'est important mais
tu sais au début l'excitation
[Musique]
me à 10h le matin dimanche au brunch là
à place tu vas parler tout ce temps là
mais tu vas pas les jeux dem m à faire
bon mais ok on écoute mais si on est
lundi là si on est lundi j'ai pas envie
d'attendre jusqu'à dimanche mais toi
aussi ta relation c'est une relation
covid ouais fait que c'est ça c'était
plus propice aussi à ce momentl la covid
de de parler nonstop mais j'ai toujours
fait ça mais mais tu sais c'était covid
mais tu sais c'était pas début covid
dans le sens que c'était pas covid
cétait il y avait encore un couvrefeu
certain ça fait 3 ans 3 ans et 3 mois
que covid tu sais il y Ava encore c'est
ça me semble qu'il avait encore le
couvrefeu mais il a tu sais c'était pas
le comme coupé ta petite mèche dans ton
front ouais ça paraît tu l'as coupé mais
dans le fond je vais te conter
l'histoire on ouvre une parenthèse ça
c'est TD ça c'est très TD ce que tu
viens de faire mais dans le fond dans le
fond justement dans la pandémie je me
suis rasé la tête ouais puis là j'avais
la petite crise de pointe d' il y a
toujours une coupe végét unete pointe
mais tu sais quand j'avais les cheveux
plus l je dire m'en crissait mais là
rosé ma petite criss de pointe à me
gosit ouais fait que là je la rasais
tout le temps à zéro tu sais pour que la
ligne soit Dr tu comprends puis là fait
tu rasais à au Bic bah ou genre cllipper
à rien là tu sais puis là c'est vrai que
là quand même drôle la longueur pendant
toutes les bout mais là c'est ça bon ok
on dirait un petit po de poussin qui P
de même pour ceux qui veulent voir là
OK puis
c'est vraiment très physiquehumour
physique pour un podcast c'est bon pour
un média comme le podcast non mais bon
bref puis là tu sais là c'était correct
parce que là tu sais je me rasais genre
mett à TR là la tête puis là ça à zéro
pour avoir une ligne drite dans le front
ouais fait quand je me suis dit je vais
me faire pousser les cheveux là j'avais
tout le temps la petite repousse là là
je la je
la laiss pousser mais là je rendu les
cheveux longs puis là j'étais encore en
train de
en même temps tellement au milieu
qu'elle B
mettre va rendu à moitié de la longueur
des autres cheveux non non mais tu sais
je vis mettre non paraîtra pas là mais
là je me suis dit là je je vais pas
raser ma petite pointe toute ma vie po
fait que là comme là je la laisse
pousser je me suis dit il a jamais
personne qui va remarquer ça col là en
attendant met du gel sur le côté puis
fais juste la swinger vers en haut mais
juste un pinch de front on dir un
gratoun mais au
mais on veut pas t'intimider là non non
mais non non mais on dirait ça ici là
mais en haut c'est ça pourrais me faire
une greffe greffe de cheveux une gre tu
mettais ton pinch bout à boute ça serait
comme uneou c'est ça mais bref je me
suis vraiment dit ma blonde aussi m'a
dit jamais personne qui a remarqué ça tu
vois elle m'a
menti parce que là on vient de faire un
5 minutes là
dessusississ j'ai tu mis mal la naise OK
éit vraent ok c ok c'est OK euh c'était
vraiment euh je veux juste oui vas-y un
complexe non mais juste une une petite
photo j'ai une petite photo juste pour
te montrer pour donc j'allais à tout le
monde ça là je parlerai de ma pointe
pendant une heure ah ouais mais j'espère
qu'il vont t'invité par
çap bon podcast ça c'est un écoute c'est
l'idée l'idée est lancé c'est pas que tu
as juste fait 5 minutes pu c'est terminé
déjà ça risque d'être un long podcast là
non ok peux faire au moins 1 he30 sur
sur ma pointe là je l'ai pas trouvé en
fait bref
pointe non c'est une photo de nous
autres quandon éta enfant puis euh
d'homme il y a vraiment pH primaire là
je genre dem vraiment le genre un un M
d'en face là cute ouais
ouais fait que là tu vas chercher ton
chat excuse chercher mon chat puis elle
m'a sdite vraiment dès le départ je l'ai
vu genre je la trouvais vraiment comme
entreprenante elle était elle full
confiance en elle conduisait que une
jambe levée tu sais pas les deux pieds
oua ça c'est charmant ben sérieux ouais
badass là c'est un moyen badass mais
quand même sais je trouvais que ça ça
don comme un tempérament arrogant plus
j' comme Nice j'aime ça tu sais parce
que moi aussi je suis arrogante un peu
puis là j'étais comme Nice puis après ça
on arrive là-bas puis tu sais c'était
vraiment céit un
appartement c'est un bloc spécial metton
là il y a beaucoup de personnes
handicapées je pense dans ce bloc là
fait que c'était mais c'était un vieux
bloc tu sais on TR puis quand on est
rentré il y avait une personne avec
plusieurs PL au visage qui était
vraiment comme
parlait comme ça puis elleit comme pu ça
faisait peur un peu là puis là j'éis
comme oh my god je suis mal à l'aise de
faire vivre ça à ma blande puis fait que
là j'ai par ave la madame un petit peu
pu ma blande é come c'est spécial mais
tu sais là on arrive chez la madame en
haut pour prendre mon chat puis là mon
chat veut il est caché il veut juste pas
sortir mais là l'affaire c'est que c'est
plein de lit électronique électrique là
pour parce que elle a comme de TR pas
plein de lits c'est pour un hôpital
c'est vraiment elle a comme deux lits
puis elle a plein d'affaires pour
l'aider dans sa maison tu sais fait que
là c'est encombré le chat on sait pas il
est où on le cherche on essaie de le
poignner il est pas bien le chat tu sais
il était il était genre poussièreux
quand je l'ai pris c'est comme pas sa
place je pense il était pas heureux là
non il était pas heureux là quand qui
t'as vu il a comme fait genre yes vient
me chercher ou dit non il a pas dit ça
tout il était caché non il avait
vraiment peur il voulait pas sortir mais
mais paraî-il que le cololloque de la
madame était pas super gentil avec le
chat fait que il s'aimait pas toutes les
deux fait que en tout cas puis là ma
bland m'a full aidé puis on est revenu
chez nous puis elle a dit regarde je va
conduire pour le retour parce qu'elle on
a pris mon ch mais elle a conduit mon
chat à première dte là h fait elle dit
prends au retour aussi elle dit prends
ton ton chat tu sais c conso le kit soit
avec ton chat je vais conduire rentre
chez nous puis il ont développé F une
belle complicité au fil du temps
puis mon chat il a slqué aussi puis
c'est plus dans le lit fait tu sais fait
que c'est ça fait que ça a été vraiment
mais ça a été une belle de parce que
j'ai pu voir comment qu'elle se
comportait avec moi avec les animaux
avec les inconnus euh le si elle avait
du L une situation pas optimale aussi
exact fait je me suis dit bon mais ça
fait ça avec moi va être prête à faire
plein d'autres affaires tu sais puis
comme de fait elle a vécu plein
d'ffaires avec moi tu sais ma famille
est vraiment particulière puis elle a
vraiment été là à chaque étape avec ma
famille puis euh c'est ça ça puis moi
aussi je suis particulière fait que elle
m'a vraiment comme elle m'a enduré tu
sais fait que c'est ça fait qu'
vraiment cé c'était pas supposé mettons
c'est inattendu c'est ça comme comme
relation ça m'a vraiment surprise puis
je pensais pas non plus que j'aurais été
game de sauter la clôture d'aller vers
les filles tu sais de sortir êt en coupe
officielle avec F ouais je pensais que
j'allais plus fréquenter longtemps les
filles puis je me suis dit non c'est le
moment ça tombé vraiment au moment que
je me suis dit là faut que tu t'ouvres
ça suffit moi je m'ouvre pas vraiment je
parle beaucoup énormément mais je parle
pas de ce qui de mes émotions là puis ça
a été vraiment dur au début on a eu
beaucoup de de problèmes avec ça puis
finalement je suis devenu vraiment une
pro en communication ouais ouais je dis
pas que je parle de mes émotions tout le
temps mais tu sais elle m'a pas encore
vu pleurer metton mais reste que je elle
a vraiment été bonne pour moi puis je
l'ai rencontré à mes 31 ans fait que sa
j'ai passé quand même 15 ans là à pas
savoir qu'est-ce que je voulais à
rencontrer des gars puis à me dire mais
mon dieu c'est pas ça je veux sais c'est
pas parce que je suis les bien je sais
pas je mets pas d'étiquette sur que je
suis mais comme il y a aucun gars
jusqu'à maintenant que j'ai rencontré
c'est sûr que vous alle me dire que je
fréquente juste des gay peut-être ça
aide pas mais que j'ai rencontré qui m'a
fait me dire ah ouais je me verais
passer ma vie avec cette personne là tu
sais t vite là h comme ou sinon si je me
t pas je cours après quelqu'un qui qui
veut pas tu sais fait c'était vraiment
juste ça mes relations puis fréquenter
des gars qui
étaient juste pour dire que je
fréquentais quelqu'un sais que ça
m'intéressait pas je voulais pas
vraiment être avec cette personne là tu
sais puis juste pour dire que je dtais
juste pour dire que sais j'avais des
relations sexuelles tu sais c'est
vraiment il y avait rien qui me tentait
là-dedans puis quand je l'ai rencontré
tout a changé même que j'ai arrêté de
manger pendant de semaines pourquoi et
ça d'habitude la maladie ne me freine
pas là tu sais gen j'avais des papillons
commment on peut dire au début j'étais
comme oh my god j'ai un cancer c'est sû
j'ai un cancer je mange pas j'ai j'ai fa
ouais je pensais vraiment que que
j'avais quelque chose sais pu mon ami
m'a dit S coincé pas mal avec la la
rencontre avec Mar pière là j'étais
comme mais puis moi ça m'a jamais
empêché de manger tu sais j'ai dé du
monde dans puis j'ai jamais arrêté de
manger à cause de ça pu dis mais ça se
place tu sais puis finalement quand
c'est devenu plus officiel entre nous
deux ça s'est placé j'ai recommencé à
manger puis j'ai plus jamais eu ce
problème là mais quand je l'ai rencontré
c'est c'est ça ça vraiment fait bizar
puissant vraiment ça m'avait jamais fait
ça je vous jure je capoté puis il av mes
amis il y avait comme deux amis que je
voyais pendant la pandémie qui venaient
chez nous des fois puis j'étais comme
j'étais stressé j'aijoyais plus mes m
avec eux parce que je pensais que
j'étais malade tu sais j'étais comme
pendant 2 semaines j'étais là
c'est ma phobie être malade d'avoir un
cancer encore plus tu sais ce qui va
sement arriver à pas mal tout le monde
dans Vie personne sur 4 exact fait que
mais c'est juste que oh my god je dire
ça ça m'a donné des fr fou he quand tu
pens ça ouais mais c'est ça fait j'
comme c'est ça j'ai un cancer mais
c'était le cancer de l'amour le virus s
amoureux et c'est qui se passait puis
ouais céit c'est vraiment mais c'est pas
vrai que l'amour c'est facile ça l'
faire c'est je dis pas qu'il faut forcer
les choses mais c'est pas vrai que c'est
facile on s'est choisi à tous les jours
on choisit encore mais on a travaillé
fort les deux là j'ai fait j'ai changé
énormément de comportement que que
j'avais de femmes célibataires depuis
toujours sais aussi puis de femmes avec
beaucoup de caractère puis de femmes qui
montre pas ses émotions qui on été élevé
d'une deune manière particulière aussi
mais particulière il y a plein de
familles qui ont été V même mais de
jeunes qui ont été V même mais reste que
c'était ça liste des squel oui
puis c'est ça fait que ma première dte
avec elle c'est ça
ça une bonne première d ce qui nous
amène à parler de de ton podcast
détestable ouais que tu fais ici aussi
exact je suis full contente je suis
vraiment vraiment heureuse mais je vais
te laisser finir que finir ta phrase en
fait j'allais juste te dire peux-tu nous
en parler ah oui s'il vous plaît ben en
fait ça fait au moins 6 ans que que j'y
songe c'est vraiment un concept que
parce que tu sa des fois on a des idées
tu l'écris tu le relis le lendemain ou
de semaines après tu es comme ah quelle
mauvaise idée tu sais puis finalement
moi chaque année chaque mois je je
risais mon mon idée j'étais comme
pourquoi je fais pas pourquoi je le fais
pas c'est une bonne idée j'im encore
cette idé là
puis après ça quand j'ai commencé à voir
des gens qu'une fois de temps en temps
il mettaient sur Instagram envoyez-moi
vos PIR dat jeis com oh my god c'est mon
concept ça ça fait 4 ans avant que ça
commence que j'avais C idé là tu sais
jeis comme h me fa Pier mon m'ener tu
sais puis là ça a commencé à urger dans
ma tête puis après ça j'ai commencé à
faire des podcasts avec plein de monde
plein d'inluenceurs qui m'vit pour faire
des podcast j'en ai fait des dizaines et
des dizaines j'aime vraiment ça faire ça
fait que j'ai aimé ça j'ai fait un peu
de radio les fantastiqu aussi j'ai adoré
la radio c'est sûr que c'est pas même
game parce que tu sais quand tu es en de
don de r pu
une non mais il est trop B mon je suis
obligé d'me j'ai mal au do continue mais
c'est ça après avoir fait la radio avec
un peu l'été des fantastiqu j'ai FF que
je savais pas comment prendre ma place
tu sais quand tu as un un Sébastien dub
puis qui te parle tu es comme FA est tu
es comme oh my god que je coupe une de
ces TR c est extra en plus là puis faut
comme tu prendre ta place làdedans mais
je suis capable d'être extra ma
personnalité est un peu extra aussi
c'est juste que j'avais pas d'expérience
comme ces gens-l fait que je savais
jamais quand est-ce qu'il fallait que je
les coupe quand est-ce qu'il fallait que
je rentre ça ça me faisait paniquer fait
que je le faisais pas puis c'était une
gang aussi là-bas fa il
chantait oh my je suis gêné je le fais d
je le fais pas fait que je me suis un
peu saboté là-dedans tu sais puis jeis
arrivé là-bas avec toutes les go du
monde je comme je vais être bonne je
sais que je suis bonne je cap
mais finalement
ça' ça m'a choqué à quel point je me
suisermé sa mais j'ai quand même aimé
l'expérience pu j'ai su que derrière un
micro c'est quand
même pas ma place mais c'est une des
places que j'aimerais prendre tu sais
fait avec toutes ces expérience là mis
bout à bout je me suis dit CRIM mon
podcast ça ferait du sens que je le
fasse sais puis là on est rendu à
l'époque où est-ce qu'il y a de plus en
plus de podcast là m'ené je me disais
mais là il y en a trop de podcast trop
tard trop tard mais en même temps je me
dis je pense que il y a jamais trop de
podcast parce que tu sa tu choisis
qu'est-ce que tu veux ta ouais c'est moi
c'est je l'entends ça il y a trop de
podcast je dire il y a personne qui dit
il y a trop de musique ou il y a trop de
films ou il y a trop de séries c'est
comme le plus il y a de choix le monde
va décider d'écouter ce qu' on envie
d'écouter puis d' puis il y a une
sélection naturel qui se fait des
meilleurs qui se démarquent puis des
autres qu'ils vont peut-être arrêter
parce que je veux dire parce que
personne les écouteou whatever mais tu
sais si pas jamais trop d'offres l' pour
le public c'est juste bon qu' a plein de
podcast ou P oui qui faisait un gag
là-dessus il dit au Québec le monde dit
arrête pas de dire il y a trop
d'humoristes quand tu vas là dans une
crèmerie puis y a 47 saveurs là prends
pistache puis ferme ta
gueule non mais genre si tout ce que
tuaimes c'est pistache prends pistache
ferme ta gueule genre c'est quoi le
problème c'est vrai c'est 100 % ça puis
c'est c'est c'est un peu ce minding là
que je me suis mis à adopter puis je me
su je me suis dit bon ben là même s'il y
en a trop pour certains il y en a
peut-être pas trop pour d'autres puis
c'est les autres qui vont m'écouter tu
sais ça sera ça puis je aller au bout de
ça par j'ai tendance à pas aller au bout
de mes affaires parce que je me
décourage puis je me d ça pa pas puis je
me dis que même si ça PNE pas reste que
moi j'ai ça va PNER mais je v l'avoir
fait puis un peu comme ton 80 km tu sais
tu as réussi à le faire au bout mais la
première fois tu l' fait jusqu'au bout
puis tuas tu es resté avec une petite
amerine de ça puis c'est ça puis ça me
tentais pas de de de rester avec une
amerine de P avoir fait de voir tout le
monde autour de moi qui qui vont
jusqu'au bout même si ça pgne même si ça
pgne pas tu sais fait que faut faut faut
que j'arrête de mesurer le le succès tu
sais le succès je pense ça va juste être
de l'avoir sorti de l'avoir fait exact
d'avoir non c'est ça exact de l'avoir
commencé exact ou exact je sais pas
combien temps ça va durer mais
l'important ça va être de l'avoir fait
puis d'avoir mis du du cœur là-dedans
puis pour revenir à ce que c'est
détestable c'est j'ai envie de parler
avec des invités et comme vous pouvez
voir je parle énormément donc je vais
déesser d'avoir deux invités h et je
vais essayer de liderder ça de du mieux
que je peux puis on va parler des PIR
dates mais là je me suis rendu compte
par que là au moment où est ce qu'on se
parle on a déjà tourné deux épisodes et
je me rends compte que c'est pas juste
des PIR dat et c'est c'est ce qui est le
fun aussi c'est qu'on parle du dating
life dating game de comment ça se passe
quand qu'on rencontre des des gens
comment qu'on se présente aux gens
comment qu'on se sent qu'est-ce quels
outils on a utilisé tu sais puis on on
j'ai eu Gabriel Marion c'est vraiment
intéressant parce qu'on parlait de avant
sa transition pendant sa transition
après sa transition tu sais euh ça CIT
un bout un peu sérieux mais a toujours
des petits gags qui qui qui rentrent
là-dedans puis tu sais j'aime ça quand
c'est léger quand même mais il y a des
moments qui sont vraiment
euh ben important à à dire puis à
écouter tu sais dans ce moment-là puis
euh c'est ça fait que je me rends compte
c'est sûr qu'au fur et à mesure je vais
prendre de plus en plus euh conscience
de ce qui va être important de souligner
mais jusqu'à maintenant
je me laisse un peu porter par les
invités puis c'est sûr que j'ai des
questions en backup mais je me laisse
porter par les invités puis j'ai
vraiment à dat j'ai du fun ça se peut
que je P un podcast de invités peut-être
vous ça va être plate à chier peut-être
avec vous mais qui sait ben non mais tu
sais je pense que ça sera jamais plate
parce que chacun a sa façon de der même
si un pattern chacun sa façon de der
puis chacun voit le dating d'une façon
différente eu puis m une question qui
vient mettons avec avec d'homme que je
vais pouvoir qui qui qui vont pas me
venir avec quelqu'un d'autre vous
m'inspirez peut-être des affaires
différentes aussi puis vous allez
peut-être m'emener aussi tu sa comme là
j'ai eu une invitée aussi qui elle à me
dit mais moi j'ai pas eu de P tu sais
premièrement comment c'est possible mais
deuxièmement c'est pas grave moi j'en ai
plein fait que tu sais elle me dit mais
moi j'en ai pas mais en a une fait que
là je me suis plus à raconter une pire d
tu sais fait que je me dis que moi je
peux pas aller à ça mais aussi j'ai
envie de faire participer la ma
communauté tu sais puis de que eux ils
m'envoient leur pire de puis j'
j'aimerais ça en lire aussi puis
j'aimerais ça du pas conseillé j'ai
vraiment pas la prétention de de
conseiller personne sa donner mon
opinion sur la situation euh personne
l'a demandé mais je la donne quand même
c'est
gratis fait que fait c'est ça je pense
ça va devenir quelque chose pour moi de
de vraiment important puis de
thérapeutique aussi à quelque part fait
que vous allez suivre peut-être une
thérapie euh peut-être qui sa peut-être
pas juste de moi peut-être que mes
invités aussi des fois on parle puis on
s'en rend compte pendant qu'on parle
c'est comme si on brainstormait à haute
voix puis on faisait comme ah ah ouais
c'était ça que j'ai vécu ah ouais tu
sais fa on assiste un peu aussi à ça
fait que c'est ça se veut drôle ça se
veut informatif ça se veut thérapeutique
ça se veut ça se veut divertissant
divertissant je
pense je pense mais oui si vous écoutez
le sansfil puis que vous voulez sauter
dans l'univers de détestable ben Dom pu
moi on enregistre tantôt un épisode puis
si vous voulez une transition subtile
vers le podcast Vanesse ben c'est la
bonne façon de le faire je de l'autre
bord par contre exact exactement ça la
transition ça faire oh ça serait tout ni
quand même on on fait ça on peut faire
ça ou est-ce que le ton épisode commence
comme ça oui ok ça serait Nice fait là
on claque des doigts ok tu faites vot
conclu dites-moi merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là on invite tous les gens à
aller écouter ton podcast de testable
qui va être en ligne quand ça ça va
sortir ça va sortir avoir déjà sorti
ouais je pense fa que le monde va déjà
savoir c'est quoi fait que là parle un
peu pour que la caméra soit sur toi donc
je vous invite vraiment à écouteter
détestable ça va être c'est ça que tu
voulais faire ben je voulais oui ouais
mais on peut le refaire ben non mais je
peux
dire merci peut-être juste merci les
gars de venir à mon podcast ok ok ok ça
on garde tout ça on garde tout c'est bon
ce qu' VI se passer mais moi je veux
juste dire oui que j crois beaucoup ton
podcast je sûr ça va être incroyable je
trouve que tu as vraiment la
personnalité pour faire ça tu as
l'expérience pour faire ça tu es
vraiment la bonne personne tu as des
bonnes idées tes invités sont le fun euh
moi je pense que ça un succès ça pas
Cassel c'est parce qu'on est amis que tu
me lèes le cul de même c'est parce que
je suis un homme blanc hétérosexuel puis
que j'ai le privilège d'être ton ami en
plus fa que ça me touche beaucoup mais
euh pu que j'aime çaicher des
cul Un petitich de cul temps en temps là
mais euh non mais tout pour dire que que
que que c'est B existant tout ça ah on a
eu du f au shooting aussi ça F shooting
on a fait un beau visuel j'ai de montrer
le visuel au monde par une par
tellementôle au shoting Mo ontait
vraiment pas
ça on s pasané là mais on était ben on v
pas les mêmes choix m de photos parce
que mais moi j'ai même pas eu senti
qu'on était proche d'acc on pas en
daccord dans sens que lui il voulait
être comme une photo de moi qui était
plus genre Louf main burlesque m tu sais
moi qui faisais ouais m'envoyé les feedb
ououa puis au début j'étais d'accord
après je me suis dit je ça soit moi qui
fait qui me suit pendant comme de temps
tu sais fait que là finalement il était
comme qu'est-ce tu en penses de ça puis
cette écriture là pu moi j'étais comme
moi je prendrais vraiment l'autre là là
lu comme tu sû moi j'is je comme non
l'aut tu es sûr moi ouais non non mais
tu sais je veux dire j'ai j'ai j'ai fait
valoir mon point après ça je dire c'est
décis la décision revient pu après ça on
la respecte puis tu sais c'est sûr
que qu'on règle nos on règle notre beef
là maintenant moi moi je sais m tes
photos que tu faisais plus une phase
drôle je trouvais ça fucking drôle puis
je trouvais que quand tu voyais ça c'est
comme ça genre ça ça frappait pu tu
avais le goût de l'écouter parce que on
dirait que ça mais la photo que on a
choisi est vraiment bonne aussi là tu
sais puis ton
vu ouaisouais ou ou j'ai tout V ouou
même si on se parle vous autres vous
parlez mais moi je suis moi Dom il
m'envoie est en l'arrière master po
ouais moi je ouis c'est ça moi je suis
moins là au de mais je suis plus dans le
toi cétait quoi tu préféris la Louf ou
pas la Louf euh moi moi puis puis Dom on
éit vraent sur la même longueur d'onde
sur le truc mais je comprends ce que tu
dis aussi tu sais euh puis là on est en
train de faire un meeting de préprode en
plein podcast mais mais les deux options
moi il y av pas y av pas de mauvaise
options en fait dans tout dans tout ce
qu'on a été proposé au début il y avait
pas de mauvaise options j'aurais été
content avec n'importe quel de ceuxlà tu
préfères que toi tu sois 100 %
satisfaite avec la photo que toi tu veux
que une photo que nous on aurait envie
que soit c'est ça l'important tu sais
puis peut-être que cétait ma pH qui
était dessus puis que je faisait une
face drôle mais que
je je que je me trouve pas beau làdessus
sex mais la c'est même pas juste une
affire de sexy c'est qu' AC réflexion
après je me suis rendu compte que ça me
mettait une pression d'être vraiment
drôle je comprends je comprends j' comm
c'était pas la direction que tu voulais
nécessairement prendre à tout coup ça va
être un podcast qui est drôle mais c'est
c'est plus que ça je veux pas que les
gens s'attendent à avoir des f rir
nonstop non plus je sais qu'ils vont
rire parce que moi aussi je je le RIS
pendant mais je me dis si je fais une
phase drôle ça annonce que genre je su
un podcast humoristique puis ça se peut
qu'en tu point un épisode tu sais le
monde quand qu'on va en podcast on parle
comme aujourd'hui là mettons nous trois
ensemble on rit beaucoup pendant le
podcast depuis le début qu'on le fait
mais ça arrive des fois que tu reçois
quelqu'un que tu ris pas genre mais
c'est pas moins bon ça va arriver dans
ton podcast probablement qu'É après
avoir reçu peut-être tes amis ou les
gens que tu connais de près ou de loin
ou est-ce que tu Esme une complicitéas
peut-être recevoir quelqu'un qui que tu
connais pas tant que ça avec qui tu vas
avoir une histoire de Ch on vient de
tomber d puis on n pas éclaté de rire tu
sais fait que je comprends ce que tu
veux dire 100 % c'est sûr que si tu
arrives sur une affaire super genre de
de comme une pire de qui a vraiment chié
pu que la personne ça gen traumatisé la
personne puis que la photo du podcast
c'est genre c'est toi
qui ça ça soit pas pensé à ça je pense
que
comment je pense que l'angle aussi
vulnérabilité est vraiment intéressant
au podcast aussi parce que justement des
podcast qui lisent des dates mettons
c'est dans dans un but strictement
humoristique ça existe déjà aussiou
versus tu sais metton quelqu'un qui
arriverait puis disait qui dirait mais P
d mais tu sais que des fois les pire dat
c'est la pire d pas nement à cause de
l'autre c'est à cause de toi c'est la
pire d c'est à cause toi tuas des
patterns ça cause toi tuas des
comportements de merde puis là où toi tu
es attiré dans les mauvaises personnes
qui fait que tu traverses en mauvaise
place ça aussi c'est intéressant
explorer là tu sais de genre de
comprendre ça puis fait ça je trouve que
cet angle là du podcast est vraiment
intéressant puis tu sais il se mélange à
l'humour ça j'espère trouver des gens
qui vont dire j'ai une pire d'ê mais
c'est moi qui le causé C pire d'ê là tu
sais moi je taconé tantôt que tuas causé
ou
il a des bonnes histoires mais une autre
affaire aussi puis puis j'ai hâte moi
moi moi ce que ce que j'aurais le
souhait aussi c'est que on on sorte des
pires dates pour faire aussi des dates
absolument débiles mental ouais tu sais
genre une date où est-ce que là il y a
quelqu'un qui en fait bien trop là tu
sais mais ça peut devenir une pire qu
c'est la meilleure date Dee Maing vie je
recommande à tout le monde qui écoute le
podcast en ce moment d'essayer de faire
ça parce ben oui on peut pas toutes
sortes de dates puis il y a des dates
amicales aussi ouais tu sais y a les
dates que tu rencontes puis que des gens
au préalable peut-être que tu
t'imaginais t en couple avec finalement
ça dev ton ami ou des dates que tu dis
tu sais des fois tu dis on va te prendre
un ver sais je t'ai rencontré
aujourd'hui pu après je vous dis les G
on va te prendre un ver après parce que
je veux devenir votre ami mais ouis oua
si on l'était pas déjà puis que
finalement on se revoit jamais
ouais c'est il y en a vous avez jamais
arrivé de rencontrer quelqu'un que vous
avez jamais revu ben oui mais c'est ça
moi j'ai reçu du monde à souper une
coupe de fois chez nous puis on sont
jamais revenus peut-être que je cuisine
très mal vous me direz mais des fois
c'est même pas parce que tu passes un un
si mauvais moment que ça tu sais moi il
y a plein de mettons j'ai une phase d là
un peu on en reparler tantôt faut en
reparler parce qu'il faut te laisser
aussi podcast mais juste pour dire tu
sais des fois j'ai passé une fois une
belle soirée j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
d'intéressant c'était comme on a échangé
j'ai comme a pris sur quelqu'un c'est le
fun on s'en voit jamais mais c'était pas
parce que c'était
unais souven oui mais tu l'as pas marqué
assez pour qu'elle fasse du temps pour
toi c'est ça qui se passe mais c'est
fucked up quand même de se dire comme on
a décidé de prendre un temps on s'est
rendu compte que les deux on allait pu
en mettre ça valait pas la peine de
mettre temp tu sais c'est quand même
quelque chose là mais le temps c'est
c'est le temps c'est c'est l'argent le
temps c'est de l'argent non mais il faut
pas être trop cupide d'env la G c'est
bon ça tantôt le temps c'est la la seule
chose la seule vraie monnaie qui existe
la seule chose qu' faut que tu décides
qu'est-ce que tu as investis ou c'est la
seule vraie monnaie qui exist le temps
c'est la vie c'est la vie la vie c'est
le temps ok fait là parle un dans ton
micro tap des doigs la gangne merci
beaucoup la gangne les deux hommes merci
beaucoup les hommes blancs é merci aux
deux hommes blancs ettéros de venir à
mon podcast aujourd'hui
détestable